all right youtube what's going on bonnie
boom
i see you six slayer pong so what's up
well let me know if you guys can hear me
how are we sounding
what's going on man that way hey what's
going on brother good to see you
fonzarelli what's up brother
i see you so let me know if you hear me
everything
in there just wanna make sure levels are
good
on that oh thank you fons thank you okay
cool
now so everybody else in the uh someone
else in the uh actual zoom call
if you guys could talk so they i can
make sure they can hear y'all as well
hello
morning hello hello
that's def all right make sure y'all can
hear the chat y'all chat let me know if
you just heard them call eastwood what's
going on brother good to see you man
good to see you brother all right y'all
can hear me please let me know that
y'all can hear them
fuzzy i need money just check martin all
right can hear all pong not good
i'm man all right thanks a lot guys so
what i'll do htk thank you oh brother
thank you it's good to see you it's good
to see you
appreciate you all right so what we'll
do we'll mute again thank you mj the
boss i see you
and then in a few we will start and uh
we'll get this thing going give me a few
more minutes
my
foreign
all right hi mike yeah all right first
of all guys thank you so much the super
chats are appreciated however we would
prefer
you guys use the link that's in the
description that is the gofundme that
goes directly
to dizzy and his family so we really
appreciate that don't
we're not going to discourage super
chats completely but we prefer to help
get there
faster so again i want to give a shout
out to the people who did donate
um shout out to dreadpool wrestling
priest brother dizzy much love we
appreciate that
and then of course cedric h with the
rest in peace wrestling i'm saying oh
shout out to husk
thank you brother we're gonna do that
and uh look we'll get started
you guys hear me now there you go solve
you're good you're good you're good
right on time right because i'm just
about to start it
okay i'm gonna follow up that mike's
one second um we got that the chats are
good
and from there everybody can go to obs
and get y'all
live on faces on screen
and here's where it all goes bad yeah i
know right and this is when the stream
messes up
all right we are live we are live first
of all
thanks to everybody who can make it you
know today we want to celebrate life
you know this is a brother of ours that
we lost recently very suddenly
and um to see the turnout by the
community was tremendous so um i want to
thank everyone for
being here whether you're in the live
chat whether you're here
on the call itself to say some words for
our brother
kevin wayne aka affectionately lord
dizzy in the community
you know we want to celebrate his life
man he wouldn't want us to be morbid he
wouldn't want us to
to feel any type of way and the show
must go on you know in his own words so
what i want to do is i want to shout out
to uh i know we got a will me in here i
want to show the gaming beyond the box
because um
they really did something very special
for
our brother and i'm going to start that
off now
so you guys in the stream if you want to
see what they put together you can watch
it now
and uh then we'll start and say our
words for our brother so
check it out welcome back to the next
episode of
after hours it is may the 3rd of 2017
and we have things to talk about
as well as drinks to drink down it's not
just regular coffee i swear
there's there's hairs
[Music]
[Applause]
last day recent treatment
just finished it up right now
and then on out i wanted to
give kind of a shout out to a few people
out there starting with uh of course
every sunday iron lords
especially to my boy cognito and king
david
all the support you guys throwing behind
that uh of course loads and edit
of course everybody over there lognet
editor
josh redding editing staff
nick ryder's hector
site manager hyde wanted to give another
shout out to
of course wilmy
from will me over to mr bloomstick thank
you for everything you guys have done
bringing on a rand and of course quick
to uh to do all that stuff take this
down
ah flam for the podcast
shout out to you guys at the shop
podcast
[Music]
special shout out to the wife
uh of course broken games over there a
weapon whale
bringing me on
and there's a lot of other people do a
shout out and everything you know
especially out there on the twitterverse
porsche over season gaming
for all the support thrown back there i
just
wanted to thank y'all for all the
support you've done and on to the next
step
one down thank you
absolute salute beautifully done um love
you dizzy love you dizzy man that that
was
special again husk will me
game behind the box really really thank
you for that because uh that one that
one really hit hard for us and um
i'll start off um you know obviously
again for people who just joined us live
stream
i just want to reiterate you know all
proceeds will be going to
to lord dizzy and his family his
beautiful wives build a child
and um you know again we're not going to
discourage super chat but we prefer you
guys use the link in the description
which is the goal for me to really help
his family directly
so um look i'll start it off man um this
was a rough week we all know it this
you know i was dreading this day and you
know it's one of those situations where
our brother
has been so strong through everything
you know he was battling the rare cancer
and you know i guess i'm part to blame
because i'm so accustomed to his
strength
i'm so accustomed to dizzy always
beating something or treatment or
anything that he went through he never
put it on anyone else
he never made an excuse he never you
know
he just never complained he just put
forward he just had this great energy
about him so um you know for me you know
i think the origin started with anchor
um definitely addict and you know those
xbox live chats and playing destiny
shout out to frodo i know he couldn't
make it
but um i just remember having a fun time
and he was just a real laid-back
chill cat and just so fun you know what
i'm saying
and we just hit it off we just hit it
off immediately um
you know we started playing more games
together and as we went on
the thing that really he made me believe
in what we were doing more so probably
than anyone else in the sense that
you know when iop started he was a way
bigger entity than i was i mean shout
out to playback gaming if you guys are
in here
you know um he he definitely said cog i
believe in what you guys are doing
so much that i would love to put your
content on my site
you know and we're like this is like you
know early origin days okay you don't
say like this is
like we're we're so you know just
started just to be honest he's like bro
you got something special
and it always resonated because he
didn't have to do it you know he was
he was selfless that's one thing that's
going to say is a theme throughout here
he he
was selfless he definitely cared more
about others than sometimes himself
and we just collaborated again that
evolved into lords of gaming.net
you know and again this is a person who
had his own established
brand his own established entity and is
willing to to just be selfless
and combined and form something and i
just missed i'll miss our talks
you know collaboratively you know our
brother he has some great ideas we would
help each other we had these
you know for the writers that are here
you know just an inside joke would be
like
this was in the fantasy football like i
was so you guys were our draft picks
so i was like yo you know what i'm
saying he's like yo i got gondo i was
like yo
son i got i got i got josh ready you
know what i'm saying like it was it was
this gay and it's like yo
my guy's better than you guys it was
just these internal fun things we would
do
and uh yeah like i just miss it and then
even the thing about dizzy working with
him every day and speaking him every day
was like we would bump heads sometimes
collaboratively and i know a lot of
people here have bumped heads with our
brother you know
said but the thing about him that i
respected is that
even if you disagreed in the moment
he would take a step back and sometimes
i would take a step back and we would
see the other person's side and there'll
be times i'm like you know what
he was right on that one you know what i
said and he he
he was just so humble about the saying
he come back to me and said cog
you know sometimes i respect what you're
saying or you know you know what maybe i
had to look at this differently and he
always credited you know
each other for keeping each other even
killed you know what i'm saying so
the other thing i remember the sarcasm
my brother was a he was a
he was a button pusher you know what i'm
saying like if
yeah like if it was a game or something
you noticed
he pushed that button but again it was
never with malice it was always
fun
okay so me and this didn't start off on
the greatest of terms
right like we did not start off because
he was out here with this destiny
bashing and
yeah he was like bro playing
quintessential destiny bastard
and he keeps putting up this arc and i'm
like yeah joint only do five frames per
second bro i i can't see it
i used to always be like i could come
play because every time
he would get me to play arc something
drastic would have happened every time
like
there would be some glitch i fall
through the water alligator eats me
oh boy we're not playing it no more yeah
i told him i said i can't get jiggy with
this
i said i said you got to stop but he
didn't and he
yeah well he kept falling right so when
the series
acts and that's gigma he got the last
laugh
oh yeah a performance bump never forward
yeah because
the joke we used to say was it rare like
a slideshow
he told me he said i told you it could
be great and then when they showed it
part two
and it had vin diesel i was like oh
they're gonna let this guy get crazy
with this game
phil brought out the checkbook for it
too now
okay so he and i okay so we started off
that way right and then
um the website thing happened
and we're sitting there because we're
going through this thing with uh
another team you know that we use with
and um
me and cog will have our conversations
and he's like well you know
diz is uh talking about uh
we can uh use his platform
i'm like what do you mean use his
platform why why would he do that
and um we got into the conference call
we got into the conversation
and um remember at the same time now
i'm like this is the same dude that'd be
talking bad about destiny
we were very protective of that i'm like
i don't know about this dude right
so he's like uh i really believe in
everything
and um i really i
i want you guys to succeed and uh
to just
relinquish the title and we came up with
the different naming of it and the
different rebranding
of it um showed a selflessness uh
and a belief system that he had and that
belief system is going to be key into
this one little story
um that i have for him and a
selflessness
you're going to hear that from everybody
here he gave off his self
and asked for nothing gave of himself an
act for nothing
um and for those people that give up
they sell an ask for nothing shall
receive everything
so when he did this um
i understood the level of uh integrity
and what type of person that i was
dealing with
at this moment i knew exactly who he was
at this moment because
for somebody to give you the keys to
their house and say just come on in come
on in
i i believe in you guys just come on in
you know uh this is a home for you and
he did that and
put the new name at the top and that
website
every time i go to that website it it
just
it blows me away but i was going to kos
and i purposely i got this statue
and i didn't know that he was a fan of
this particular character
until after i did the kos and
i did the kos and was with god uh
god doom on throne from uh zion and i
did it and i was i loved that character
and i was
you know always fight with everybody
like thanos but doom is
marvel's real big bad that's the one
that's the child that they the prodigal
son that they wanted to be
he loved the evil dude and
when i told the story he knew the story
so then after that you know we start
vibing on
and talking about it and he was such a
fan of doom and i'm like man i didn't
think i could meet somebody that was a
bigger fan of doom than me
but i had something that he didn't know
that i had i had a
a legendary uh marble scale toy
and uh you know and i had it upstairs
and i had that thing for probably like
15 years
15 years and i said your dis you'll send
me your address
okay so he's he sends me the address and
i send it to him
my god the text because i forgot i send
it right
for the text and the pictures and he's
going nuts
and i knew because you know i just want
friends and loved ones to have a a piece
of
of me something that something to
cherish right and i wanted him to have
something of
me and i knew he was a fan of it to
cherish and and to appreciate it
because it was sitting in my closet i
like
doom a lot but he loved doom yeah and
that needed to be with him
and when he got it i knew he appreciated
it to a level that i could have
never appreciated it too and i was just
so happy that
uh the time that i had with him he got a
chance to uh
see what he gave to me because when he
said coming to his home
with open arms he gave up himself and i
wanted to give of myself as well
to him so i'm i'm happy that that
happened um
and i do appreciate all the times that
we do have and
in my phone his name is saved under
dizzy the man
because he fought
cancer
differently i'm not saying that he
wasn't
afraid because if he was he never showed
it yeah he showed it
i'm not saying that he didn't have
doubts because if he did he never told
it
he handled it like an iron lord
he handled all his problems without
one complaint without
one whine or cry or moan
where other people would have broken
down with how many times he had to go
back and do this but when we talking
he's optimistic this is the one
this is this this is gonna be it and i'm
with you or a joke with it
so it hit me like a ton of bricks for
that not even to be the thing that take
my man
out yeah you understand that that dead
i know it just it just really sucks
that he battled so hard to get so far
but
he lived every day can't take that away
and he was truly an inspiration to
everyone that has met him or that knows
them
indicative by everybody is here
absolutely i want to get
a couple of lords i know lord i'm from
laws here are on time constraint i want
to be respectful for that
because obviously we could blow the a
all day so i want to get obviously um
let's start with i know uh bill
i know your time is limited solve your
times limit we got a couple lords here
that
and i believe uh obviously reaper and
stuff like that so i want to get you
guys in
any order you know just your thoughts
about our brother
as we celebrate him on this day anybody
could start
um yeah i'll go um i i knew i knew him
in a different way than a lot of the
people here uh you know he was
as someone who worked you know first at
xbox now on oculus and worked in gaming
i got to i get to meet a lot of people
just by happenstance right i
find them on twitter i find him in these
kinds of things
originally he was just at some level
another face in the crowd but to his
credit
um he you know it's something about
someone's character that when you meet
lots and lots of people in a casual way
some of them rise up
and some of them stand out uh as
something more than that right and so
um the first thing i'd say that i
appreciated the most about him was we
would we would argue on twitter
it seems to be consistent that's gonna
be the consistent thing
yeah right um
which was it was it a final fantasy 6 or
a mass effect one
like what was the contention i mean i
think it was everything it was
talking about destiny it was talking
about like it didn't matter the topic he
had an opinion
yeah and he was going to let you know
what it was facts um and it was either
with you or against you he didn't care
um but i i will say that so um
just from a community perspective the
one thing i i appreciate
the reason i wanted to come talk about
it today was
you know we get caught up in the
performance of a box or which game is
better than what other game
and there's been two articles in my life
that i've read about gaming that have
stuck with me the first one was about
the
the guy who raced his dad's ghost in the
racing game
and then and he couldn't beat his father
right after his father passed
the second one was kev's article about
gamewood cancer
um it came out i think about a year ago
now
and it was it was a simple article right
it was just like
hey this is what i'm dealing with um
some of you know i'm
my family's dealing with something
similar and it happened right around the
time that koben started
and uh the thing i love about it
is he to the point that you guys were
making about how positive he was he
talked about
here he's dealing with this horrible
thing and you know
treatments for cancer are brutal right
it's all it's either cut it out or burn
it out there's no
cure and he was just taking those hits
and he was dealing with it and he used
gaming
as that thing to ground himself but it
wasn't just that he used gaming what i
loved about the story he wrote
um was how he talked about
the community that came with gaming and
how it gave him strength
to deal with what he was facing and just
sort of internally and never
in any way other than the positive vibe
about
this community whether you're on
playstation or xbox or pc
or switch or mobile you didn't care
right gaming just made him feel good
gaming gave him that strength and it
shows i think why people need art
like not just gaming at all but like
life just kind of keeps kicking you in
the head
and uh you need something else to to
refocus and center yourself
and uh you know to me that'll always be
his legacy
he knew this community and this
entertainment medium was what gave
everyone strength and brought everybody
together
and uh you know it's it's it's a shame
cancer sucks yeah covered sucks um
and uh that'll be an article like if you
haven't read it i recommend you go and
read it
um that'll be another one that'll stick
with me forever and i hope that'll be
his legacy
people remember that level yeah it was
it was a good one we definitely
uh as a as a site as a team to
immortalize him we uh
we put a lot of his almost like a
greatest hit shout out to heidi's in
there he
did it and uh that that article
definitely hit different for a lot of
people because a lot of people
had uh their eyes open to that reaper
i want to get you in here brother i know
your time's limited and you are
one of the homies you are one of the
guys that
i was introduced to from his original
crew you know what i mean your family
frodo you know swat the whole crew so um
talk to us man i know it's been a rough
week but um
we got to celebrate our brother man we
got to do it
yeah one thing i will say like you guys
already touched on he was uh
he was not a non-combative person he
enjoyed his arguments more than
anybody i know he'd jump into an xbox
live party with him and say hey man
how's it going i've been talking a
couple days the first person i was
malthus who the hell are you
a friend for 20 years you don't have
anymore appreciate it
um yeah i remember
when we first started gaming together he
uh we actually played battlefield bad
company too
joined the party with um about 20
minutes each one page goes you know man
i think about starting a gaming
community in a gaming clan i was like
all right cool you have fun once that
like
good luck bud and then the next day text
me
hey man you know like change your clan
tag to lna i was like what's lna and he
starts going on about leapfrog thing
alive and how that all started
it's just amazing to see how he started
something so small for a small group of
friends of his that then grew into
something much larger and had a bigger
impact on the community
and uh she sucks and it's gone
i'll feed you brother
everything you said resonated because
that that was that was definitely our
brother
and um he was all about community you're
absolutely right he was
all about community he brought so many
people together
and to see the stories that everyone's
coming up with that
things i wasn't even aware of and um it
just goes to show you how much he
touched people man and
like i said i'm so glad you could make
it you know this i know how hard this is
for all of us
especially you and um i'm definitely
appreciative that you that you made it
brother you you meant a lot to him
you meant a lot to him and i know i know
this is tough for all of us brother
um i want to again respect everyone who
still have time solve
i know your time is limited as well um
let's get you in just uh for time's sake
you guys can hear me yeah you're good
you're good
you got to speak up a little bit solve
it the mic's a little low sorry brother
okay so anybody that you guys would
everything that that meant this from the
moment i
met was it
was putting other people in front of me
yes
and in my specific interactions
giving us a platform early on and then
even when we had another opportunity
and he said go take that out yes
good point and then and then you know
with
no ego whatsoever he said
go do that yeah remember he told us he
said you guys do do what's best for you
guys that he said i can't
you're absolutely right i forgot about
that continue i'm sorry
and then for us you know for that
opportunity to end
and then he came right back to the table
with us and like look we're gonna do
this let's grow this
and for someone to take the things
they've built from the ground
up their dream and say
build this thing that i think
the world are on top of what i do
and sort of pushing it to the side a
little bit
and for something else that he believes
in who does that
who does that i don't i don't know if
anybody that felt
facts so it was an honor and a pleasure
to know
i'm sad that i'll never in my life get a
chance to give my brother a pound
and a hug i've never met him i'll never
get the chance to break bread with him
have a drink with him you know the
things that
i get to do with the cod and and
and i'll never get the chance to do that
so my heart still breaks for his family
but
it was quiet for his friends everybody
was
so close to him and i'm a little
champion because again
i never got to meet the man first but
um yeah i mean obviously
there was about a year and a half period
there when king and i had a bet going
right and dizzy was the one that was uh
he was in there just kind of egging both
of them
yeah and it was you know this is sarcasm
because
you know every he would put in the chat
every every sunday like
this is just to remind you
and guys and then when king was like
well oh dizzy i don't see in anything
but color
and then he started super counting
and then you know there'll be moments
when other news about back to back would
come out
um and then disney would come he'd be
like i don't know
i think we might lose this one stop and
i'm like dizzy stop helping me
and at that point you see that he was
just trolling both sides of the argument
how he defended lognet and how he
defended iot
um it was in the early days of
blockchain very early day with vladimir
and and we sort of got left in the lurch
when it came to
uh editors yes so it was just
his myself before my life got turned
upside down
and uh and cobb um and it was
rough going because we have you know god
bless everyone who came to us
he came to write her for life at the
beginning but
there was some rough pieces that came
out
so some editing was a little sus you
know
yeah that was it was just difficult it
was you know there were some pieces that
really needed a lot of work
and there were three people and you know
for me like
more and more i had to i had to kind of
remove myself from it
because of my work situation this was
obviously going through treatment
and things like that so it was you know
it was difficult for him and cog was
doing a lot of administrative stuff that
wasn't
difficult but we you know there was some
light at the end of the tunnel we
started getting some good writers coming
in i remember specifically editing an
article from a writer named josh ready
and and and i remember it because i was
like wait a minute
i didn't have to do this much to it you
know i was like
there was a they were like trying to
pull out the red pen a little bit but
not that much i was like i was
pleasantly surprised i was like yes um
and and i remember that i felt good
about that i was like okay we're getting
an influx of people who have
a history of writing and uh
i remember him dming me i think it was
in uh
in discord he's like hey um
are you the are you the editor-in-chief
and i'm like no
what's going on all right thanks and i
didn't get any other message
so a few hours later
he's like emergency meeting yes we go
let's get to it
we gotta get to that moment it's a
perfect transition to josh by the way
emergency meeting yes
josh had some grievances with disney
and dizzy is living that was a hot one
never seen dizzy living now we need to
go in and referees
yes and so
but we get into the meeting we get into
the meeting
and josh again josh is super passionate
and i think they they both recognized
that about each other yeah they learned
about each other that day yeah
he's very yeah he's very direct you know
he has
he has a military background he's very
direct no hair that's air force in the
building
exactly exactly and then so target and i
are you know we're pragmatists
but at the same time we try to be
diplomats as well right so we're
trying to referee this thing and and
disney was so angry because he felt that
josh was being very accusatory of him of
like
listen you guys promised me this
professional like you know we're trying
to work towards something big
and a lot of these articles are going
through not in the greatest shape
right and uh you know disney took
offense because
god didn't know what was going on behind
these things but there was
plenty going on behind the scenes yeah
um and so we got in there
and i let josh explain it you know
thoroughly what we got in there
at the end of the day what came of it
was that
there was an understanding and it and it
speaks to the measure of both men
yes that that they came to that
understand um because they i i you know
it was good for us to be in there todd
and i but i think they would have
settled this themselves as well because
that's just who they are
and when you realize that the person
you're arguing with has the same
end goal yeah that's what it is yeah
middle ground is always to be found
and then uh ultimately you know fast
forward just a little bit after this
meeting at alex josh
you know talked about it more in detail
in the relationship but
um you know when dizz which was kind of
heavier into his uh his treatment and it
was difficult for him
you know again selflessly he tells pog
look
josh needs to be edited that was bro
i'm glad yet that was the moment i hate
to cut you because that
that is when not only was the
understanding between those two because
you have these two passionate
people who love writing editing knowing
how a website is run
but as things started to progress with
his condition
and when he pulled us to the side and
for him to say
josh needs to be the editor-in-chief
moving forward
again the ultimate selflessness of i'll
let you finish then we give it to you
it exemplified everything that he did
and it wasn't
it's not hyperbole i've never
been there very few people in my life
that i've met that are willing to
sacrifice
themselves that much you know and people
who are always on youtube
and social media there are plenty of
people out there that have
you know big followings or not and are
literally afraid
to share their knowledge because this is
this fear of
of of you sort of usurping them into a
point or something like that
that was never him he wanted to bring
out the best in
every year and
man bro i miss you
i love you man i
josh i gotta transition to you after
that story there's no way i can't
so josh talk talk to us about about your
really good art with our brother
just in general your experience yeah i
don't know some i don't know what you
thought of me
then because that was basically our
first interaction was
becoming like a bull in china
the funny thing was like no because i
remember our interactions that we had
while i was editing your piece
and you know you were very receptive you
weren't combative about anything
that i said so i'm like all these guys
when you're calm relaxing
so they got to them two got in the room
i was like oh really i wanted to see it
i wanted to see it because i'm like oh
you know immediately i think dizzy at
the beginning of that meeting
dizzy it didn't seem like he liked the
fact that i
agreed with you i just didn't agree with
the way you said it
but i did agree with you and he was like
wait a minute trader yeah
[Laughter]
perfect perfect transition man yeah that
was that was one of my first
that was one of my first interactions
ever with this dna actually
that's why i asked because i didn't even
know who the other and she
was uh cog brought me in
right when when khan brought me into the
right and
and cog and i mean 14 maybe 2015 at e3
yeah 2015 maybe 2016 uh and
we had just kind of randomly kept in
touch over twitter and over facebook
but like i wouldn't say yeah i wouldn't
say we were best friends or anything but
he knew that i
i was a writer and so he reached out to
me about writing game stuff and
uh and i said yeah that sounds that
sounds like fun it sounds like a good
outlet
it's uh i i love video games i've been
playing since i was
four years old and um but i've never
written anything you know for a website
before so i don't really know how this
goes
and uh but cogs like yeah we're playing
together this thing you know we wanted
to be
uh you know the neck kotaku and
uh and i said hey that that sounds
pretty cool
i want in on that so um but yeah i
remember just
uh pulling up some random sampling of
articles after i had written a few
pieces and just being like
yo this is not this is not what i want
my name attached to
we need a quality upgrade here and i
just came at dizzy
and i was just like yo i write
really good like i know i write well and
my my level of writing is going to be
the level of writing that's on this
website
because i'm here and if i'm here then
everyone needs to
needs to come up to me and our brother
was like who this dude think he
is he's like but it
realistically i have to cut you i'll get
right back to you it was a philosophy
difference because he did understand
your point
i think where his side just came down to
which was like look
we have to look at what we have here
right yeah and we gotta
we gotta build guys up that that's
definitely i'm sorry
and even more than that was he believed
in people's voices
and he believed in the voice of
each writer really coming through in
their pieces
and that was something that i didn't
understand
when i was writing because i just i knew
how to write
very technically sounds how to how to
build a narrative in a piece and
and and write as a professional and i
don't think that i have a very strong
voice but i do have a very professional
voice
and wait what disney understood was that
that's what what the community
loves about ilp and what the community
loves about
about streamers and about writers in
general it's not that the pieces are
professional what they love about is
that the pieces convey the hearts and
minds of the writers
and of the the streamers and of the of
the people
and he was really good at
bringing that out of people and
encouraging people to
to be themselves and stay true to that
and and that was something that i didn't
understand
and he taught me that and for that i'll
always be grateful
and um i feel like i came into disney's
story
kind of at the the final act if you will
where
you know when i met him it was you know
when he had
was just being diagnosed with cancer and
he had this long
past with playback and with the iron
lords and
and all the stuff that i still don't
know the complete story of everything
that all of you been through together i
just you know here when i get famous
he was my boss over here
there you go drop some balls for us in
the video i'm sorry yeah he was
he was my boss for a hot minute and then
uh
well he was still my boss but i just
have to listen to him nearly as much
once i took over
but uh he was the opposite of every
texan i've ever met
and that he didn't shout to be heard
but when he talks you want to listen um
and you know i didn't get into all the
twitter
arguments with him and things like that
you didn't engage
i i just knew him from business like we
we had a business relationship
no no doubt i feared that for the fame
brother i know you've been sitting there
is there a counter argument no no no no
no you're good you're good you're good
you're good
i'm sorry if you're finished i'm going
to call it i'm sorry josh if you're not
finished
no i just i'm gonna miss him um
he had a vision for what he wanted logna
to be
and and i'm really glad that i was able
to be a part of bringing it to life um
you know we we hit a half a million
views on the website
earlier this year after just under two
years of launch
um we have almost 40 000 people come to
the website every month and that's
you know our our first month we had i
think it was like 6 000 people come to
the website
and and it's just just seeing
the growth and the awesome writing team
we
we have so many of our writers here we
got mahmoud and macho and pd
and and nick was here with us her for
a long time and
i'm i'm gonna i never met him you know
i i don't i don't have years and years
of history with him i got
i got two and it feels like it wasn't
enough
and you know i said and i wrote out a a
tribute to him
the the night that he passed and and i
just i sat on it because
i feel like it's not good enough and
that if he would edit it he would have
found things wrong with it
[Laughter]
and uh
he was a good man and and i feel like
there's a lot of people that want to be
great men
and not enough people that want to be
good men who's a good man
and and every time that he came to a
writer's meeting his
i could see his son run around in the
background i just i know he was a great
dad
shout out to parker always on that girl
oh yeah we heard [ __ ] i have a
one-year-old son now
and i just i wish i would ask them more
about how to be a good dad
um i
i feel i feel for rosie and
um
i'm gonna miss him he's he's he's not
hurting anymore which
that's that's a blessing and you know i
know he's looking down this live stream
and just saying you guys are being such
saps
but uh yeah he was
he was great so um yeah that's that's my
piece
but i'm honored that he chose me to to
succeed him as eic
and and i hope he was proud of me yeah
he believed in you brother he believed
in you he told me the talks
so many times he was like he's like josh
we're in good hands he always told me
that and you have nothing to worry about
in that regard for sure
fame i want to get you on brother
because i know you've been sitting in
the car and i don't know how long you
got
and uh you you have a tremendous story i
i was finding out things from your
stories on twitter
that i didn't even know about 2xp
obviously me and you reconnected you
know with
level one but uh talk talk to the people
man to celebrate our brother man
how you feeling yeah man i i i
definitely don't want to hold um too
long i kind of want to get to the point
that i think everyone here
really would speak up that that dizzy
was two things he he's someone that's
gonna leave a life
long effect on you um and to his
toughness
um i believe i i met demi and i but i
believe
i believe i met dizzy through uh
anchorman anchorman
because they're both from texas and then
i found out he lived like right down the
street
and so we're in a call and i'm not too
far from
uh being just a hardcore madden player
that's all i played with madden i just
got really
into the gaming industry and i'm like
y'all want to go to e3
and this is like e3's cool and all but
if you met that
you know about this this and this and
after i get a dm
i'm like who is this kid like just
sending me uh
retroperlusa
what yeah going on like who is this so
we started to talk i'm like he's like
putting me on game like yo
oh you're in a bad spot for hopefully
you can get you better your butt and
crazy bottom a little bit
oh man do you mind you're about to do
try turning the camera off
of fame and see if your audio comes
through
[Music]
damn he taught a good story too i don't
think he can hear us yeah he probably
can't hear us he probably can't hear us
at all
i'll text him real quick yeah just text
him real quick because this is he's
about to get into a good one i can tell
yeah just text him real quick all right
he's got
let's see if he comes back yeah
hopefully he comes back
but um hank i mean if you want to
transition and you can you can if you
want i know you're talking to him
um can i say something real quick of
course of course
you know first off i want to you know
we do this community we definitely
bicker at each other a lot but
this chat is just
wow like there's people
i'm so glad that people put this
this whole nonsense on twitter aside and
everyone came together because
i don't think look how many people this
man touched
like i'm just i
i can't i feel your brother not for you
it's it's beautiful wow it was like
every time i opened twitter there were
200 more
responses to cogs posts about it just
it was so cool just
you don't realize how big the community
is
and how many people yeah
oh absolutely
we got somebody and watch and engage
and so they all it was i was crying
all right oh yeah brother hey um
anchorman are you back i see fame all
right
fame looks like he's connecting but give
fame a shot again to finish his story
because he definitely is about to go
into it
he's connecting the audio we'll see if
he can all right he's connected pay me
back fame you back brother
yeah can you guys hear me yes yes try to
try camera
off because your remote maybe that might
give it give it a shot
yeah and i apologize man i i wish i
could have been at home over my pc for
this so
that's okay um i'm hoping not to still
hear me now yeah you're good you're good
yeah you cut out about talk about
but yeah he he hit my dms and he was
just hitting me about
wretched lose and boogie and quake and
it banks out
and at this point i'm just trying to
really learn to get my foot in because i
i have no idea what i'm really doing
besides you know following behind
anchorman and now dizzy
um like i'm gonna keep it short but
as we connect as we talk about you know
our you know love over football and we
both live in living in texas and dfw
area um i hit him up i said hey man i'm
i'm really trying to
i want to start a a podcast 2 xp i was
like i need somebody
number one as smart as your knowledge
but you and the ones gonna go to
bathroom me
uh with me because at that point it was
a debate show xbox versus playstation
was the original
terms of the two nx and the p and uh he
went
and said yeah man let's do it so we got
together we we got with nick and kron
girl we started two xp podcast
and that's why i tell people like i
would never 2xp podcast wouldn't be what
it is today it wouldn't even existed
um as far as level one gaming wouldn't
have existed
without uh dizzy going on the adventure
with me
and um you know he didn't really know me
from a annealing
haystack but he you know he he just it
was just a good person
that wanted to go hang out we got to try
something new let's do it and we
did some episodes was having a great
time and you know we we continued to
talk
you know offline about just about life
and
about sports and and and he will
continue
to give me lessons on stuff even when
you know he he left he joined it uh
he started doing things with ilp and you
know i started level one
he he was there every step of the way
yeah um
like i was like hey i don't know what
i'm doing just like give me five minutes
and i got you you wouldn't sit there and
just walk me through something i'm like
this man has a million other things
going on in his life he has a whole
nother organization that he's up and
running
why the hell is he helping me and it
just goes to show that that
you you didn't have to be nothing but a
human being and dizzy was going to help
you if you needed it
absolutely brother just to continue to
speak on this toughness we
we spoke a couple days ago on the 22nd
and my
my battles and my my time with with kovy
was well documented and um
he messaged me and he was asking me
questions about it and
just because and i talked to anchor
about this
looking back on it now was like was i
just so
enraged like just so used to him being
so tough and just getting over stuff i
didn't really think
that he was hurting as much as he was
hurting because he was asking me
questions
and i'm on my end i'm just casually
asking he's answering his questions like
yeah abcdfg
not thinking that he was actually you
know beautiful because he wasn't
somebody
it seems like we'll just having a normal
conversation mm-hmm
um and i just look back and think like
what
what a what a he was made of stone he
was made of iron
not not no puns attended like what a
what a stone cold killer this man is
that he can
go through all of this on top of beating
cancer and we can have this conversation
and me not even knowing that he's going
through so because i missed the twitter
stuff so um i just i
wouldn't be like and i'll continue to
say it i wouldn't
be where i am without dizzy um hell of a
guy i feel for his wife i feel for a son
um if you got to know him you're going
to have an everlasting effect
something about your life will be
affected because of him
um and and it sucks man he's he's
definitely going too soon
i do think um like everyone was saying
he'll be looking down and like y'all
need to calm it the hell down
calm down but he was an amazing person i
wouldn't be who i am today i wouldn't
know the things i know
uh without dizzy um and i i i
i miss her i miss him i wish i could
message him right now and help him
he can help me get through some of my
problems because that's what he was me
he was a confidant he knew stuff
um and he never had an issue helping me
out and that's just though
so what what what a man he was he was a
man
and uh i i bought much respect
you know to everyone who who loved him
as well and
um i really hope the best for his wife
and for his his son
and um for the iron lords family i i
i hope you guys continue to push and and
make them proud and i'm gonna do what i
can on my end because
you know a lot of us wouldn't be in the
positions we are without dizzy uh the
man left the mark
and that's something to be proud of i
already hope this son
when he goes up and see the the the mark
he left on everyone's lives
uh just just by being a stand-up man
it was a man yeah brother well said well
said um
and again i love the point you made
about you know
him helping you the selflessness with
him
helping you get your situation started
and again just in in the world we live
in especially
competitively as content creators or
whatever these are things you don't see
you know everyone is so i'm holding on
to their secrets and i'm not going to
help this person because he has a rival
website in this
but you said it perfectly you know what
i mean because
that is such a rare trait and i'm so
glad you said that brother because again
it exemplifies
our brother um i see a couple of veggies
can you hear me yeah i can hear you now
there you go fawns what's up brother
um yeah this is a rare sighting for me
i'm not usually on camera right now i
appreciate you
i literally recorded a closet so that's
why it looks like this
um you know you got to do what you got
to do but uh i just wanted to say
something because i'm on limited time
too
i've been up all night i've been at work
all night but i stayed up for this
because i just wanted to pay my respects
because um i you know i first met diz
back it was a couple of years ago uh in
in the ilp
chat actually and you know people that
know
diz knows he he likes to mess around
with you in the chat like he likes
to get rises out of you and then that
man uh
he got a couple of rises out of me
i knew what he was doing i i i saw what
he was doing after a while and i go i
know this guy's game
you know uh we had some you know talk on
games and stuff final fantasy 6 final
fantasy
7 that whole thing that was a
contentious one
i was talking with you on that my man
second with you on that yeah
but it was it was just like who is this
guy
i thought he was a really funny guy
after i caught on i said this guy's a
really funny guy i like this guy
and then what really struck me about
this this man
is that i i first heard him
he might have had a video up or
something back in 2019
or he he might have posted something
about playing his switch during chemo
but his first round of chemo the second
time it came back and i looked at him
and i
and i'm like this man is like just so
positive
and and you know i it blew me away the
way he
went about talking about it so i hit him
up in a dm
not never even talking to him in a dm
before just interrupted him uh
interacted with him through chat uh
and uh so i hit him up with a dm and
you know he hit me back well thanks for
you know thinking of me blah blah blah
you know
and then we developed a rapport i
considered him a friend and
anybody who knows me if i consider you a
friend from time to time you might get a
dm from me saying hey
how are you doing because that's just
you know that's just me i need to reach
out to people from time to time and
you know every time i'd reach out to him
that man never complained
never that man never complained and
people talk about his toughness and i i
gotta tell you he's
he's the toughest dude i've ever met
okay he might have been small in stature
but that man was
tough all right he was crazy fawns like
sometimes i forget he has cancer yes oh
they're like like six but i'll be
talking to cognito and cogniti will be
like
uh you know we'll be talking about
lognet stuff he's like you don't want to
put too much on dizzy because of his
condition i'm like oh yeah that's right
because he never brought it up
ever never never and i'm the one who was
like how are you and he's just like
i'm good man how are you and
it's it's crazy like when people talk
about his toughness that cannot be
you know it's not an exaggeration and
the guy never
showed his you know his hurt or anything
it it
it was amazing to me and you know him
being a father and all
you know that that really hurts me the
fact that you know he
he's got a child and you know his wife
and everything but
yeah yeah condolences to the
you know to his family and to everybody
who loved him and everything he was he
was a good
good man good man absolutely
anyone on time constraint i want to be
respectful and get you prioritized
gene i see you raise your hand so uh to
me dizzy will always be the guy that um
the beat cancer if you if you looked at
the the photo he posted
getting married at the town hall how he
looked then to the last photo he posted
about about two weeks before he passed
away uh it's night and day
you know to me disney he he always will
be the guy that beat cancer to me
um after you know 30 successful uh
treatments of radiation
um i've had some amazing opportunities
here working with the guys and i'm so
happy
uh to work with the guys and in covid
it's kind of it made us all
it makes me at least feel a little
scattered you know um
we work really closely at the
conventions and i'm gonna miss that a
lot and i think that
this is gonna be a great opportunity to
to put us all in check and make sure
we uh stay closer together even if it's
another year or two years before we're
out of connection you know because
i said that yep i hope that that this is
something that happens that
puts us in check to remind us hey let's
let's stay connected to all this
absolutely you know
i never disagreed with dizzy on anything
we never fought really
but i would uh i would chime in on
something on twitter and i would get off
and come back
whether it was bill or college or
whatever that's why i liked you
i come back and there's 60 notifications
photos josh who who approved gene as a
writer
who was the one that signed though i
don't remember i'm going to say gina ply
but i can't remember
probably dizzy was the one that pushed
that through he was probably like he
agrees on everything
he said we gotta get this guy i gotta i
need i need another ally
mass effect final fantasy yeah i liked
him and this said you
definitely like him
i'm sorry if he wasn't finished brother
i'm sorry no that's a little anecdote
something crazy uh happened last night
involving dizzy
we are all on kind of uh separate sides
of the world it feels like in our
personal lives and
and i shared the gofundme for disney and
i live in connecticut my best friends
live in connecticut my friends are
family we all live in connecticut we've
never left
my best friend's wife who is a military
child
uh she grew up with dizzy i didn't know
that wow
and they went to high school together
wow and uh dizzy and to
josh's point about texas dizzy grew up
in kansas i found this out last night
was there yesterday
missouri guys hit me up saying i went to
school yeah yeah
yeah missouri he went to knob noster
high
oh okay yes sir this is a family show
we're brothers salute for the brother
that's it i'm gonna
miss him and i'm gonna miss some of the
calls uh once a month and the kid
yelling in the background
yes uh joshua got to fill in you have to
fill that void
josh you got to keep the tradition of
the of the kid in the back
yeah he has no problem yelling no no
dealt man
and he was on top okay straight
otherwise i would give it to some guys
yeah you know what uh
can i jump in if you don't mind
absolutely yeah i actually have um
two great stories about this let's go
the first one is i i just want you to
know hello my name is craig i'm a victim
of that meeting between josh
and dizzy our brother let's go because
you asked me to write a piece
oh i forgot you were the center of the
argument yes
i wrote my piece and listen i'm not
literally
literal genius here but you know i wrote
police reports for a living you know
what i'm saying so you had to be you
know you had to be perfect with these
things otherwise you go to jail you know
what i'm saying
you have to be very articulate so i know
how to write
and i wrote this piece and i put my
heart in i worked overnight that was
like
midnight two o'clock in the morning
josie gets up she says what are you
doing
i gotta finish this and three o'clock in
the morning i'll be in the room
so i'm writing and i'm like my god that
is the best piece i ever wrote my title
my
my god ign is going to hire me
and i said i send it to cogs like okay
we're going to send it to disney he goes
listen
i just want to give you the heads up
right now awards
he had a big fight with this this this
other dude that really knows his stuff
and you know you might be a victim
because of this
dizzy hits me up privately and he goes
you know hey bumble appreciate you
writing for you know for the site and
everything but you know we got a lot of
problems
and i'm like what do you mean we got a
lot of problems i said i put my heart
and soul into it i wrote four hours last
night on this and i said i even went
back and i re i read it three times
he goes yeah but you know you got to cut
out this point he sent me this
it it went from like five pages
three pages were gone i'm like
where are my three pages he goes yeah
but you know what you have to you be
your opinions are too big
about the gaming industry you you can't
name drop ign
and i'm like well why not i said they're
they're terrible over there
i said okay you know what i'll put i'll
pull that out no problem i'll take that
out
i'll take out kataku i'll take out all
the other
all the other posers and i'll just
generalize it
so then i'm like okay i don't like see
i'm old school like i've been gaming
over 40 years i'm 50 years old you know
i've been gaming since
the atari 2600 so you know i've been
here a long time
and i remember racing to my local optimo
to buy magazines from og sites like
die hard gamer and video game
you know a video game a pc and all and
and i
loved egm the way they used to write we
don't have writers like that anymore a
lot of these new kids
they put their opinions and not facts so
i wanted to talk about
that you know we've seen a change over
in the writing and he was like wow you
know
rewrite it and i said rewrite it
i said i just spent four hours last
night writing this thing i said no it
says i went i said cog listen
here's the thing man i i don't think i'm
cut out to be a writer because
i don't know about this i dizzy dude
let me let me let me talk to him
dizzy hits me up privately again he goes
you know i talk with cog
you know i'll put some of the stuff back
so i actually i said well
let me see what you got let me see my
own work and what you're doing with it
because at this point i'm ready to just
give up yeah remember this
he comes back and he's
and there's a there's a paragraph and i
said but wait a second you only added a
paragraph
i i called i called cognito
here's the thing was
you know what i'm just some knucklehead
who started a podcast i don't know [ __ ]
from shine mold you know
no problem i'm gonna pull my article
forget it and i took my ball
and i started to walk home with cogs
take it easy
take it easy we can work this out i like
what you got
maybe we can get him to understand it
needless to say
the article finally went back and it was
my article i don't know
who they had to fight who he had to
fight if he bumped him over the head and
and then slipped it to josh when he
wasn't looking i don't know because
otherwise
i mean but that's the one story and
the other story is a little bit more
touching for me personally
because i unlike nintendo guru had an
opportunity
multiple times to work with
i dizzy on my show yes and one of the
one of the
the the the appearances by him that
really stands out for me personally and
it just goes to show what everyone has
been saying about how
selfishly that he is like he he
loved gaming he loved this community
i invite him and he he dm's me and he
goes listen
is it gonna is it okay for me to be on
my phone and i'm like
yeah sure why why well i'm gonna be
doing a treatment while we're doing the
show
okay and i mean come on man i mean how
what what do you
say to someone like that you know what
i'm saying i mean
i didn't know him that well i got him on
my show maybe six seven
maybe even double ditch at times but
every time he was on he was
a true champion and you know what i i i
think
um uh attic said it you you didn't
you always forgot that he was fighting
cancer
yes like it was never the forefront of
the conversation it was
it was just incredible and you know
something real quick because i know
rosie is listening and i don't know her
but you are a wonder woman and
you know he used to talk about you in
american brother
the best way possible and
his life was better because you were in
it and actually and his son
and you guys i i trust me if if my if if
mrs boom ever went
i would be lost so i know how you're
feeling but
you know i'm glad to be here i'm glad to
be here boom he loved you man
he loved you he always he always one
thing about with his treatments and
and and the thing that you said that
again with the selflessness and
you know he was he would be on us for us
not to continue
because with your show with our shows
everyone who has a podcast here
or will me all you guys
were his therapy he he would be in that
chat
you know what i mean whether it's riley
somebody up or have you tried with me he
just could never get it he tried he
like he would he would go at me in the
chat and he actually dm
one day's like boom i can never get you
and i'm like because i'm easy as pie
brother
but yeah man and i'm glad you said that
a bottle because uh yeah
that that meant a lot brother i wouldn't
get undead
i know his time is limited i know he's
got the kids so i want to get it i'm
dead we
we had a good working relationship with
you and um
definitely had some some great times so
talk about our brother man
what was your experiences bro see it it
makes me smile
a little bit to hear everyone say that
you know they bumped heads
which is you thought you was gonna be
the uncomfortable one in this no
no no i knew i wasn't gonna be the
uncomfortable one um
the best part about me and this
relationship is we
built a relationship over the past year
and a half but the two years prior to
that
he had me blocked yeah twitter like like
dizz had
had me blocked on twitter and to this
day and i wear it with pride he has me
blocked on facebook
to this day
i me and him had very differing
viewpoints on a lot
of things and there was a lot of other
people's drama that me and him got
involved
with early on and we took sides
and we never quite got over it at that
point in time
so i ended up getting into a situation
cog went hey you should come right for
lognet i'm like i don't know this really
doesn't like
i forgot about that
we had to negotiate a peace treaty i
forgot
i'm like i'm like this really doesn't
like me and i'm like
like i could bury a hatchet but like he
i don't think he likes
me and kyle goes no no no no don't worry
i'll smooth it all
out so i i get i get brought into log
net you know i do a couple pieces they
upgrade me to editor me and dizz have
not said a word to each other at this
point
i get discord message at i don't know
one o'clock in the morning from him
he goes hey man um can you look over
this piece for me
i'm like yeah sure what is it and it was
just gaming with
sir peace so
here i am one o'clock in the morning
jonesed out on red bull
reading reading this piece
and i cried for a solid five minutes
after reading that piece yeah
i've never read or edited something
that hit me in such in such a way
and it completely changed my perspective
on diz as a person because i never knew
about that i think that speaks volumes
about him
is like this whole time that me and him
were fighting
gnashing at each other and all this is
he was going through something truly
terrible but
he never let it be his personality or
anything like that you never heard about
it you had to ask him about
this man would literally come in and be
like hey man i know you've been having a
rough week i hope you're doing okay i'm
like man you're
on like 30 treatments right now why are
you checking on me
i should be checking on you and that's
just the kind of person
that dis was he was combative but it was
never personal
right if you ever wanted to talk to him
he would always give you the time of day
um this is a man who i went from never
talking to
and interacting with to him opening up
his home and being like i gotta get you
an anchor down here for quakecon
you guys need he's like you don't know
you guys don't know home cooking and
he's like don't let anchor convince you
that carolina barbecues
anything oh you took that vomit
thank you i present that remark
definitely barbecue argument yes
foodie we forgetting our brother was a
foodie yeah continue
he was a cook man there was a two-hour
xbox live party with it was it was
anchorman
me and there was somebody else thrown in
there i
forget who it was it was just literally
an argument about
who had the best barbecue
and i'm just sitting there i'm just
saying they're like i live in canada
they're like no no no you shut up you're
not part of that
disrespect the canadian you know
that texas barbecue life yes i forgot
who was trying to represent north
carolina
and i live in kansas city that would
have been me sir
from north carolina
[Music]
we had the barbecue argument is a yearly
argument that starts up around memorial
day
every single year we would have this
argument we're like nah nah nah
you can't you know what what about a
memphis style ribs and [ __ ] like no
no no that's mm-hmm not the same things
you know what sounds like kansas city
barbecue
oh my god vinegar
and i just i think that speaks so much
for dizzy's character
is that like in a matter of two months
me and him went from
not talking not being friends and
everything else to him opening up his
home and being like
you can come stay here we'll work and
just
it's heartbreaking to me because like
even post me leaving lognet like me and
him talked a few weeks ago but you know
once covid clears we'll you know we'll
go to quakecon
and you know we're gonna do this and
like i was gonna have him on my podcast
when i got out of the hospital because
it was like
it's been said numerous times but you
just never expected dizz not to pull
through i remember like when his wife
made the post that you know he had covid
and everything else and i was like
man that's rough but you know he'll pull
through he always does
and you know when he didn't it
it hit different i was at work when
ivan messaged me about it and
i've never i've never been one to cry
publicly or anything else but i i broke
down at work
i have no problem demanding that it was
it was hard
to you know was behind a wife that
obviously you know she must have had to
battle with him too because he's
stubborn as hell and you know any woman
that can battle with dizz toe to toe you
must be one hell of a lady and and you
know
his son is was a feature
of log net meetings of parker come back
with parker
oh like it was just
it's hard it's just i can't put into
words it's just it's hard
to it's hard to put a value on how
somewhat how someone can touch you in
such a short amount of time
and i just remember he sent me a video
and he said it was his mentality
with dealing with cancer and it was an
interview with totalbiscuit who
you know passed away from cancer and he
talks about how you know
when you're going through cancer
treatment and everything else you know
you have bad days
but toll biscuits methodology was if i
had 13 bad days but one good day out of
14
that's worth living and that channels
dizz's energy to a t this is a man where
me and cog
and josh have literally threatened to
take away editorial powers from
because you'd post a pending article in
the chat it'd be like one o'clock in the
morning you'd see dizz
oh i can grab that no no go to bed
go to bed from the hospital bed
editing articles remotely during
treatment and we're like
bro
[Music]
yeah the the work ethic and everything
that man had
you know one hell of a role model and uh
his memory will live on with everyone
he's touched and i think
you know we we've lost a lot of people
in this community over the years
but i haven't seen such an outpouring as
i have
this week between nintendo guru and
uh now diz and just seeing everyone come
together and just bury
so many hatchets yeah and everything
else my only
like message i think you know as
everyone stated this is sitting down
going
you guys suck stop stop stop
um but my one thing is it's like don't
hold grudges
you know find that person that you know
you haven't talked to in a couple years
or you've lost
touch with re reignite that friendship
talk to that person again because you
know what you never know
when someone's time might be up so take
those opportunities while you have them
because you will regret it if you don't
and my only regret
is not burying the hatchet with this
years ago and getting
more opportunities to talk with a guy
who
is just so incredible in everything he
did
and will forever leave an impression on
how i act as a writer
as a person and more importantly as a
father
well sad brother and um i'm glad you
mentioned the story because um
you know with you you know you were kind
of like at the time the big free agent
acquisition that i had to fight for and
um
you know i remember bub buffer heads
with this on that initially
and i was like what's going on you don't
say it then obviously you explained the
history but
it's so funny because once you guys got
in the room and you talked
and and then those meetings and he
pulled me to the side and was like [ __ ]
he's the right guy you know he's the
right guy and
during your tenure with us he really
appreciated he saw
the you know the beauty of your writing
and what you can do in the potential and
then we
and then when you moved on he obviously
told me he's like brother he's like
we're so proud that we are creating
something
that is a jump off point for a career
possibly and that's something that he
always told me that so
it was he was again so selfless because
most people are not going to
help someone leave their organization
to become something great somewhere else
some people will keep that selfishly
and again that's the beauty of them and
i'm so glad
that we had that run together you guys
had that run together because that was
pretty awesome
again i just want to be respectful for
people on time constraint i want to get
them
yeah i want to get them to go first you
know
yeah i i want to go next yeah please
don't go for it let me tell you the kind
of person dizzy was
we uh i've known disney since like 2013
2014. i've known dizzy for a long time
and there's about i don't know that's
about a year and a half we weren't
talking we
we that was real remember
i remember we we started talking because
of a destiny right again
and it's just like it was never brought
up ever again
it was not ever thrown back up in each
other's face like
that was the kind of dude he was he's
like look once once
we move past something we move past it
and you know
i remember it was like it was in
november and
i was sitting i joined a party with him
and john and
he was like why don't you come play uh
art the annual
arc for some reason like
something in me was like just download
arc and play with them
and you know i'm i'm really happy that i
got to do that and
we played that for like i would say six
seven
hours and you know it i hated it
you did your prison time like i did my
prison time when i lost a bet to him
you know i remember hating every second
of that
the only the only reason i played is
because on the series actually it's not
a powerpoint show anymore
yeah it's nice now yeah i remember when
i hear heard in past
i was in shock like i i did i didn't
even get on twitter
the rest today because i just i just get
emotional i was like i got to stay off
all forms of social media
and i just sat there i was like i am so
thankful
that i i got on and i played that ark
with him
for that six seven hours because
he was him and john they they were on
the ark binges the conan binges i didn't
get to play much games with him like
ever like
survival but it's just like i remember
making fun of him because this damn
thing was 110 gigs
and i was like you know how much of my
heart space this is taking dizzy
it is just like i was just i was so
happy
because i did that because it's just
like at least
i got to spend a little bit more time
with him than i normally do and
you know i i talked to him on like the
18th
and i asked him how he was doing he's
just like i'm just tired and i'm
short of breath and you know i told him
i was like
i said bud just get some rest man you
know that's the last thing i said to
dizzy
and you know i sent him a message on the
22nd
but he he was already you know
in the icu by then and it's just like
you know
i'm i'm so glad i got that that arc with
him
yeah i appreciate it brother i mean
again the stories are consistent
and um i remember y'all wore i forbid it
you had a little more off of it
and it's like i said he it was never
brought up ever
again yep the thing about to see you
guys come together because again
i was it was dizzy it was a while i'll
just do dizzy through
you you were part of part of the the
people who introduced me to him you know
i mean those those xbox live party chats
and stuff so um
again it was great to see that and um
like i said
it was he was something man he was
something he was selfless i'm glad you
brought up art
i'm glad you brought up him always
promoting it you know that was his game
and he gonna ride for it and survivor
level was a steak you know i mean and
shout out to the clan too remember chief
tommy big bad john
all the art guys anybody who in here who
played ark with him we're going to talk
about that server
also you know and keeping that alive and
whatever you guys want to do because
that was his heart
you know and i remember when ark two was
announced that i would affectionately
tease him but
i was surprised it it was it was good to
see something that he held up right
arguments
that helped the ninja theory versus we
could go on like he
he was the guy that you'd have these
fun debates with man so every time
something funny in the community
happened he'd send me a screenshot on
twitter
yeah he's he was he's a trickster man oh
you love it absolutely it's just like
you know
one of the biggest things that that
dizzy contributed iop
was was how our chat is because me and
dizzy used to go back to back over our
channel
because i felt like you should be a
little bit more free from and he was
like
none of the no the f stuff none of it no
negativity i want it all gone
and then after a while i'm like fine
dizzy you win
it's it's it's just like you know and
that is one of the reasons that our chat
feels so comfortable because
we have zero tolerance for foolishness
so
no salute you're absolutely right great
moderator
he he was a mainstay in that chat every
sunday you already knew what it was
anybody
who is on time and straight i want to
prioritize you guys
back i gotta go but you guys have a good
day thanks ahead
i appreciate you brother slow i heard
you and then after that
i think macho i think i heard you too so
let's get you guys in
slo you know i i got a work stuff that's
starting to pop up so i wanted to yeah
just just speak real quick before i head
out um
all these stories have been great
because i as
others have said it just validated um
and it
made me feel a little bit better about
how some of my arguments went
with disney because look if you guys
know me and dizzy's uh
uh history and in the the iron lords
chat on twitter the
the frostbite wars have been real okay
it's it's been real i i mean i i have
never seen anyone
capped for frostbite
doesn't cap for frosty
because he would have promoted that
thing it still wouldn't have worked any
better
but he would have promoted it so well i
mean like
it started with that i think it's
probably was like i i
interacted with him um frequently but
not
to the this degree we were in the iron
law show i think it was right around the
time
jason schroeder came out with the report
on bio
on bioware what happened yeah and just
i'm in the chat just
speaking the truth you know the truth
right and i'm just like man
the issue is frostbite clearly clearly
they are being forced to use this
engine and then out of nowhere dizzy
comes in he's just like
no slo-mo you're wrong what's up with
dice dice doesn't have these problems
what happened with dragon age
acquisition and i'm just like
uh i i wasn't thinking about it like
that no way i'm not going i'm not going
to get back down so i
know like we kept going and going so
it's just been this thing between us
where
i i knew well and and for taking the
test to it
he couldn't even tell when i'm about to
do it and we'll be doing up we'll be on
brad or whether we'll be on our show dps
and i just be like yeah man you just
like i would just throw a shot at
frostbite
and i'm telling you it's like the bat
signal would go up
and dizzy would come in the chat and
he'd be ready to go
it was hilarious i loved i loved that
about him so much
that he he's so much like me where when
you are
when you are dug in on a position
and you just don't give and it was it
was that
that argumentative side of him that i
also have
and i just enjoyed this so much arguing
about that
uh arguing about ark i mean like him
telling me that you know like
what i think we had a joke on twitter
once and i
and i was i think someone else has said
you you should you should let your kids
play arc
and i and i think i said something like
well i don't want to kill their
enthusiasm for gaming
and then like i mean literally dizzy
came in and like the cape comes on
um i mean as as early as the 18th of
february
i uh the news came out about uh i think
it was the netflix marvel
shows um potentially going to disney
plus that's it
oh they should they should replace uh uh
kristen
ritter as jessica jones and he just pops
in you have the worst taste in the world
i'm i'm going to miss it so much and and
it's not just the
the sniping back and forth cog you
probably remember my grounded live
stream
oh yeah so i lose a bet i lose a bet the
vortech
so so forza is here for say i'm like
forsake
i need you to make more videos and he's
just like man i'm busy i'm like man
whatever look
and they've been trying to give me the
playground just the longest time
i said i will play grounded i would do a
video i said i would do a video on
grounded
if you do seven videos
in a week and you nearly killed them and
i that part i do enjoy because forte was
definitely
tweaking by the end of the week
right but he got it done and i got i
said all right i'm gonna do a
live stream of it this live stream oh my
god i mean
i'm i'm i'm glad was good entertainment
for everyone else for me it was just
getting getting punked by
ants and and grasshoppers all over the
place but
the funny great thing about dizzy dizzy
was in the chat giving me pointers
because he's into that survival yeah
you're right
his thing and so like as everyone else
was like man slow-mo that that ain't
been killed you about seven times
already
dizzy's like hey you know you could you
should probably build this and build
that and
you know over here in this area there's
there's some stuff some resources you
can use i'm like
oh they i i didn't expect that from
disney
i was expecting you suck at this game
right
which is clearly what was going on but
i mean just an awesome guy i uh we had
them on dps
uh when we did the live stream with
video game awards and
and and a little mini show and
afterwards and i mean seamless as if
as if he and he was just a part of the
panel with me and forza
i know sometimes being forced to get
into it and it's like no one else is in
the room we just arguing one another but
dizzy was just like oh no
you're throwing little points in here or
there it it was it was great and i
i i'm gonna miss seeing him
just always being around always bringing
good insight
always uh keep me grounded when i get a
little crazy
that's uh yeah i i i wasn't
i haven't in my time in this community
has been about three years
i haven't been close to too many people
i try to keep the circle small
and i didn't know this personally as
well as everyone else did
but he grew into
someone that i could consider afraid
i feel you brother we feel you we feel
you
yeah yeah so it's it's um
i remember sending him a message last
saturday
and as you guys said like he never
talked about the cancer
never complained and when i realized he
was sick again and i
saw the messages i was like oh you know
what i haven't heard from him in a
minute
let me see the message and say you know
what
i'm thinking about you i know you're
gonna pull through man
yeah brother we all i i will say this
he kicked cancer's ass yep
factual it wasn't cancer the guy wasn't
cancer
he handled that no well said brother i
say my same experience to uh
you know sending those words back and
forth to him
you know during the final couple of
weeks and just being happy to get any
interaction with him
but again never a complaint just just
pushed on man
he he was he was something he was
something for sure
macho i believe or someone else again
we're trying to respect yeah
straight people first and we'll get
everybody i know aims got to go wilmi's
got to go a lot of people got stuff to
say
but i just want to respect everyone who
was only here yeah
i'll be i'll be quick um
it's it hit like a rock when the news
was dropped on us
at where's the gaming.net for again for
those who don't know my name's hector
this is an assistant editor at lords of
gaming.net also known as macho
but um i was stunned it's
you never realize what days you're going
to be your last or your
your close one lasts and if there's
anything i learned from
all this is just from dizzy most of all
i learned a lot about myself being with
lords of gaming.net but the things i
learned from disney was just
always be yourself never be afraid to be
who you are
because you're going to regret it if you
don't and
because he was always who he was there's
no backing down from him whether
he's being argumentative with them or
he's just joking around but
the dude had a sense of humor like no
other um
he was just so funny and i loved sending
his tweets over to my fiance about his
animal crossing stuff how he had like a
serial killer capybara villager and
everything it was
it was the funniest thing in the world
and we just we connected over that and
just our love for gaming in general and
again his his message that he just
always spread was
to reach out to people and give people
voices and he did that for us at lord's
gaming.net and i couldn't be any more
appreciative of that
his kindness goes so far
and the one lesson i'll carry with me
for life and i'll always try to remember
always have the strength
to carry with me is to always be kind to
one another
because you never know what's going on
in the other person's personal life
and i yeah it's it's hard to
see to say that he's gone and but
you know we'll always remember him um
yeah it's it's it's
it's tough it's tough but i think we're
all gonna just
go through it together and always
remember him in the best of ways and
especially in this live stream here
where everybody's here and kind of
gathered it's it's
a great thing and just to see
everybody so happy with their memories
and so fun
and it's it's my it's amazing so
i just say thank you dizz for everything
that you've done everything you will
continue to do
beyond your life and yeah i mean we're
we'll carry this legacy for you lords of
gaming.
no we keep it up baby how do you stop it
you already know yeah so
thank you guys and it's great to be a
part of this and
much love to you guys much appreciate
your doctor he had love for you king i
know you said
you got to get ready yeah um i'm getting
ready to leave uh
i just want to say to each and every
last person that uh take time out in a
day
uh to watch the live stream to listen to
the live stream
to donate to uh uh through super chat or
to
even um donate through the the gofundme
uh even if you can't just being here
saying a prayer
just uh wishing his family well his son
his wife
his family that remains uh and everybody
here who is affected by
uh this wonderful uh selfless uh
individual
that uh i will call friend till the end
um
i just wanna say thank you to each and
every last person
who's here thank you for your time your
effort and your energy energy is
definitely needed and
it's a positive thing i lost one of my
most staunchest defenders on twitter oh
he rolled for you
he rode for you brother if a dude came
out of pocket
and i wasn't online i just found my
twitter
blown up because dizzy then set fire to
him because
dizzy was a writer what he
yo king he would oh i would have to calm
him down
could be a courageous king and i'm like
i love him
i love him
i love him because
i really don't got to do too much work
so um but this this is all games here
and love
and i do just appreciate everything i
swear
you know i'm not a guy to cry unless i'm
watching a a
documentary on dogs um but uh
this dude had me messed up for a couple
of days so you haven't seen me active on
twitter
because i just don't want to have
nothing to do with negativity i just
really can't and i just want to stay in
a positive state
because uh this this man exudes
positivity at everything so um
just just god bless guys and i'll see
you guys on sunday
um you have a wonderful uh rest of your
day
and i'm just gonna reflect on some stuff
peace king we are
we love you brother you already know he
loved you and it was great man it was a
tremendous run i want to give it anyone
else who who
want to go either or they have time
constraint you guys are open to to to
talk
hey could you you guys hear me i can
hear you i get you all right yes yeah
i gotta i gotta i got a few minutes i
want to chat real quick um first of all
i
i just want to say something this this
is amazing
you know i've been watching this while
i'm working
seeing everybody come in to
the live stream whether it's the live
chat
or or here here in the zoo meeting um
i think just speaks volumes to the
impact that this gentleman had in the
gaming community
his legacy is going to live through
through all of us here in the community
i have no doubt about it you know i was
thinking about
and i and i heard a lot of people talk
about his how
selfless he was which is
in my experience at least and i hate to
say this not not one that i've come
across a lot right
where you know i think nick was talking
and nick talked about his opportunity
and
and kind of dizzy's response to that how
he's happy for him and
what you guys were talking about earlier
how you guys kind of went did your thing
and he was like hey do
do what you guys need to do that level
of selflessness you know you don't find
that these days
a couple things stand out about at least
to me about him
and you know i wasn't as close to him as
as you guys were but you know has had
some interaction with him and
you know with what slow-mo described
earlier with the uh the frostbite stuff
and he would literally
like like slow-mo is not lying like we
we would even know he was in the in
like watching brap and all of a sudden
you see i
dizzy he's like hey like out of nowhere
somebody threw the frostbite bat signal
up
watch your mouth slow-mo i mean
immediately or
he jumped into someone's podcast to say
i'm here to make sure
brad and slo-mo and forte ain't gonna do
such-and-such slander
yeah cognito's not gonna do this he
would jump in a podcast to where you are
if that subject
was gonna come up yes to combat his
point continue
he was waiting i'll literally be sitting
there waiting like
i'll be listening to talk and i'm like
man dizzy go show up in a second y'all
yeah no he he and he and he would i mean
he was lit he was there the whole time
the whole time he was there um but
you know and i remember cog uh you know
and
you know some of the dm's i had with him
that we would talk about you know my
favorite topic media bias
we would kind of talk about that a
little bit i heard you guys talking
about how he would
he was one for debate and we would have
some interesting conversations about
click bait and and stuff like that and
because he you know he
he he was and rightfully though he he
was i thought he was really
his critique of the gaming media was was
spot on uh sometimes you know
with some of the clickbait stuff kind of
that they need to do better and i
certainly appreciate that perspective
but um you know the i remember when i
first
kind of met him and you know kind of uh
learned his story
i had no idea that he was sick that he
was battling cancer
uh i i think [ __ ] you may have even told
me because
any interaction i had with him and this
is the one thing that that
will always stand out to me about him
his his bravery
uh you know the his his positive outlook
on life
um the fact that he never he was never
like
woe is me my life is sucks i can't
believe this
he like you would have never guessed
that he was going through this
and cancer is not an easy battle i saw i
lived i lived through cancer with my mom
she had breast cancer i saw her go
through that and i know what that
battle's like it's not it's
it it is hard and and he
he battled it and he was always positive
and you know if it was me like real talk
i'd i probably would be like oh man
i i i don't know if i would i would have
been able to be as positive
as he was and i and i never knew that he
was battling this again i think until
you told me cog and i think that was
he had a level of resilience and
positivity that i don't think i've ever
seen
anyone have anyone you know and and
you know i'm you know i i i have some
you know
outside then maybe my mom just seeing
her go through you know cancer but
the guy was he was so strong so selfless
and
you know he touched so many people and
um
you know when i got he was like like i
was talking to king and king's like yeah
i feel numb and i'm like
and i couldn't figure out how to
describe how i felt
but that's how i felt numb yeah you know
and
again and this is coming from somebody
who i didn't have the relationships that
you had with
him the iron lords had with him and
everyone else this community
but that's just the amount of impact
that he had on even someone like me
you know to have that kind of impact and
you know
gonna miss him i'm gonna miss him and
you know when i when i got the news that
he was in the hospital
um you know i wish i would have engaged
with him more
i know i said i said hey you know i
figured he's going to get through this
too right
it's like this is what he does he's a
warrior
and i think part of me feels like man i
took that for granted because
life is there's no guarantees and
and it was a reminder to me that
we've got to cherish every moment that
we have and
even if it takes you know 10 seconds out
of your day to
reach out to someone say hey how's it
going how are you doing
do it because you just never know you
don't
you know i i never not once in my mind
[ __ ] did i ever think
that we'd be having this conversation
today no one did
no one did and when i heard the news i
was like no way like i just didn't
expect it because
i was so used and i probably
took it for granted yeah the fact that
my expectation of him was
oh he's gonna beat this too he's got
this he's a warrior
the guy's strong he's like superman
you know and but um
his legacy is is going to live on in
this community i
i don't have any doubt about it just
seeing the the outpouring of love
and everyone here um taking time out of
their day
you know to to celebrate his life um
he's going to live on and and cog he he
embodied
the what i think of of of the iron lords
man the
the brotherhood you guys you guys i mean
you know [ __ ] you and i talk quite a bit
um
and you're one of those guys too and
everyone on the iron lords that i've
come across
you guys are very caring individuals and
he embodied that
to to a t uh but that's gonna live
through
that's gonna live on it's gonna live on
through you and the gaming community
uh and everyone uh that he touched uh in
his own life too so
for sure um look rest in peace i dizzy
we love you
we're never gonna forget you you're
gonna live on forever and
your memory is gonna make a lot of us
better because of how you lived your
life
absolutely absolutely well so i
appreciate you
for coming i got to go gentlemen but um
salute
salute for little brother and again much
respect
the resilience the strength everything
you said because uh again i think
sometimes
part of us did take his strength for
granted he beat everything
and i think that that is definitely
definitely a good point
um i know a couple people here i'm gonna
respect our time constraint lord first
or anybody else who wants to talk next
please okay hi yup absolutely brother
long that's owned by admin
is probably not as unique as i thought
it was because we started arguing
this seems to be a theme that's that's
yeah that's what's going on
with me you know kyle came
up hey we're finally ready let's do this
website
but you know what you need to talk to my
man first he set me up
he's like he's a little hard-headed
petey smiling guy first
to my wife i'm just like i can't take
this guy
everything i say is the opposite i've
had to pull these conversations the pd2
continue this is great
you know but i don't know man just like
as the days went on and we built that
website together there's like
we just got to sync like real fast and i
mean
everything just flowed from there you
know there's like just hearing him
from him every single day about the
website um
and just a quick story to tell tell you
what kind of dude he was
um when this whole covert thing started
my wife's a nurse
um man i get a a letter in the mail
which who sends mail at this at this
stage of the game
and he send my my wife a card oh saying
you know i appreciate what you guys are
doing
oh my god you know here and some gift
cards like
that took me back like who does that you
know i never knew that brother
yeah man and uh it's tough man and then
hearing from him
i hit him up on like the 15th like hey
how are you doing but
knowing him he's at the hospital i'm
like okay he'll be there for a few days
it'll be a wrap and he'll be fine and
he'll be back to it
i actually had a one of those xbox
kishis on my cart
and i was just waiting for him to tell
me what hospital he was in so i can send
him my xbox key sheet just to keep him
busy
you know and it's hard because it's
still in my cart it's like
it's tough man i'mma really miss him
yeah man he he he loved you because um
i remember again when we we the early
days of formulating
vlognet and those meetings and um i told
him i was like you know hi
i'm gonna go back and he's like i gotta
see about your man it was almost like a
it was almost like a rite of passage
where he had to give
you to see but the thing about him
was just you know yeah you he would
needle you he
these requests at all wild times of the
day but it was all about improvement it
was all about making us better and then
you sit back and you say you know what
you know you get in pocket because you
know where it comes from
and then he would get in pocket with you
and understanding yeah you know our
thing too so
yeah i got like 100 notifications oh
yeah hi can you fix it
that banner man if he don't get a hold
of you i get the message
hey i hit high up i hit petey up and
this should have been done yesterday
like
he was notorious at working us to get
his agent to go but he'll get it done
though he get it done
he'll get it done salute anybody else
want to go up next man
over floor oh i've got i've got one if
you want me to go ahead
yeah come on will be okay i met dizzy
i'm pretty sure i met him through undead
and jared
that was the first time i'd met him and
he showed up
in our chat one night for gaming beyond
the box
right after the show was over i got a dm
from this
and he says man you really just don't
care do you
and i i messaged him back i'm like about
what
and he put l.o.l exactly exactly
well the funnier thing was i really
didn't know dizzy
then and i told dizzy i'm like well why
don't you join us one week
so he had actually been on our show a
couple of different times i talked to
him in dms
i had no clue he had cancer oh wow
he never spoke about it ever
and you know he would i mean he would
just shoot me this crazy dm from time to
time
and i had no idea until last year when i
messaged yukon
when i saw the picture of him at the
hospital i messaged you
and i'm like is dizzy okay and you're
like you don't know
and that's when you told me he had
cancer because he had never told me
he had been on our panel and he never
told me
so we had no clue so that's when
i got back with you and i'm like we need
to do something
you know because i know he was going
through those treatments and they were
having a hard time
we tried to set up the fundraiser for
him last year it's a beautiful thing
brother that was and you were trying
you were trying to go through one of
these donation sites and i'm like look
dude this isn't gonna work this is gonna
take forever
so i'm like we'll get boom involved you
know we could we can put it on boom's
channel
and i said i'm going to get mike your
bar remember to have that one way or
another i'm going to get quick
on this damn podcast and matter of fact
i called boom and i was like
look you borrow's probably gonna block
me when he searches my twitter and sees
all the crap i post online
i said but i'm gonna try to get mike
yamara on this podcast
one way or the other so boom and i had
started planning it out
you you were involved meet you blooming
king
we got it all set up and last minute
mike yamara finally messaged me back
and i told him look dude we're not
trying to bug you about anything
we're not going to ask you for codes we
don't want anything free
you know this is just this is a gamer
he's battling cancer it would be great
if you could come and join us for the
show
and of course we couldn't keep dizzy in
the dark but he had no idea mike ibarra
was going to be on the show and
a bunch of us pulled together i think
rand was there with us too randall thor
we had all these people on and right
went quick
jumped on in the uh chat
dizzy messaged me and goes how did you
get my kid
how did you get quick yep and i told i
told
you know i told him i'm like look dude i
was determined one way or another
you know we were going to get mike on
the show with us
and luckily it worked out but the funny
thing was about dizzy
he messaged me it was about two days
later
and he sent me a really long dm and
sometimes he would do that
but the thing was unlike most of you i
never argued with dizzy
when he tried to start something with me
okay yeah that's cool
i saw i saw it enough in the chat yeah
you arguing enough with christopher hart
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah so i was
good i wasn't going to argue with him
over anything
but he sent me this long dm and he
thanked me for everything
and i'm like look i'm not the only i
wasn't the only person involved you know
i said boom had a hand in this cod
king and he goes but you don't even know
me
[Music]
and i'm like well that's beside the
point dude
i was like you know we just want to try
to give you a hand try to help you out
and he just kept saying but you don't
know me
why did you care and
he made the comment he waited about 30
minutes before he responded
he's like so underneath that crazy
southern accent and all the bull crap
you post online
you actually do care
that sounds like dizzy that sounds
exactly like dizzy
i couldn't help but laugh at it dude and
then the day
during the iron lords when uh i pulled
that notorious stunt with ken getting
his chest tattooed
dizzy had a small hand in that but you
know you don't have to tell king
really what's the origin story real
quick
what did dizzy do he kind of told me
where to find it and
he directed he directed you to the
patriot until with the action oh my
we were wondering like yo how did people
find this like we
never expected that to happen it was a
great i mean it came from the inside
dude
you know he got to tell me he goes well
you know if you can log into the patreon
site you know it's right there
you just keep scrolling i'm like ah
there it is
yeah yeah i remember when that happened
too because i was in the chat
um talking to dizzy and we were egging
it was like yo what exactly everybody
was like yo what's gonna happen here man
what
when we about to do something we all i
kept seeing was dizzy in the chat saying
wait it's coming
it did no no bs we were sitting there
and you guys were taught
me it could whatever the heck y'all were
talking about just went out the window
for about 15 minutes because king was
sweating
because katie was up there and he was
like yo what what did he do
what did he do oh man i wouldn't expect
it one
involved in this oh my god it's about to
be a rap
all of a sudden just directs um
directs them to the screen and puts it
up and then cox says oh my god i see it
i see it movie the king is like
see what see what it did also we start
pointing to the patriarch
and i'm like yo brother it was a moment
so see he he had a small hand in it like
i said you don't have to
keen although he may go back and watch
oh he goes
okay i mean that's great you know it was
just every time i'd ever talked to dizzy
man he was just
you you knew you didn't know and i mean
i've got you know i've got employees
i've got grown dudes man that stub a toe
and complain about it a year later
hey man you remember that time i stuck
my toe on that couch oh god dude it
still hurts so i wake up in the mornings
you know and but dizzy just never
you know he never complained ever
and he did message me a few weeks ago
because as a matter of fact
it you could it's almost a week to the
date i mean a year today
that i had coded and izzy had actually
messaged me
because he knew i had had it and he
asked me you know what i went through
because i've got severe asthma and i'm
diabetic
and you know he had asked me about it
and i told him what i had gone through
and apparently he messaged a few other
people as well
yeah but uh you know he just never
and like somebody else said i forgot the
dude even had him yeah
that's that's how he i mean he he just
never
mentioned it he never complained he was
always positive
yeah and the bad part is
good people always go too soon yeah
and he was one of those guys man he just
he never had anything
bad to say and when he realized i wasn't
going to argue with him on anything he
brought up
then you know our conversations took a
completely different turn yeah
but you know he was just and i didn't
even realize it had happened because i
thought he was actually doing well
yeah so i didn't even have a clue yeah
it was but yeah man he'll definitely he
was definitely one-of-a-kind
oh for sure that's that won't be another
dizzy that's for sure it won't be
another dizzy
that's definitely that's nice that's
something and he also uh
he also helped me with that one chip
challenge
oh man he's a fly you two look inspiring
okay i get it
[Laughter]
the king went through the one chip
challenge pretty easily oh my god
salute to him it just it sucked i had to
be at work you know and couldn't uh
watch it
but yeah dude he he was just definitely
one of a kind person man i'm gonna miss
the hell i love him dude yeah i'm gonna
miss him too because i always got
messages i got at least
one or two messages from him every week
yeah he always checked in and like i
said he had tremendous respect for you
guys
you know when you guys came together
like that your story with the um
the thing that we did you know and boom
and quick
and i think ram was a part of it and he
was so
taken back by that with me he and it
just shocked him
it shocked him he he to see the
community
piled together the way they are now
shout the randoms in the chat right now
they just said he loved it because ryan
was a part of it um
it he was blown away and he would be so
proud right now to see how the love the
story everyone's got a dizzy
story everyone's got a story when he
touched him in that way whether it's fun
whether it's you know just needling
whatever it was
and um but i remember him pulling me to
the side and was like wow you guys
didn't have to do that and
but at the same time being appreciative
of
oh yeah of what was happening and and
how much helped it was received
and the community stepping up so it was
i always want to thank you for that with
me for really
you know spearing the charge on that and
your selflessness
and he had a ton of respect for you man
and shout out to gaming behind the box
because
he loves you guys he's like these guys
just do what they want
you were part of that podcast rotation
that he would regularly
try to get in you know everyone was you
know mostly here
you know he would try to get in their
podcast and whether it be to just
interact to to needle or whatever but he
was part of you
you were definitely that for sure oh
yeah and like i said man he
he he would message me on occasion he'd
be like why did you talk about this i'm
like
you've been in our show dizzy you've
been a part of it we're random
yep we don't care don't care and that's
that's just the thing man it's just
about having fun he goes yeah but
sometimes you guys have a little too
much
fun and i'm like all right dizzy have a
good night
but yeah i mean he he was definitely
something man
so well king's not gonna be upset sorry
we'll definitely definitely relay that
way he'll listen to it anyway gentlemen
it was fun and i just wish we could have
gotten together under different
circumstances but my phone is ringing
off the hook
it's okay brother my emails are going
haywire so
everybody have a great day and busy we
won't forget your brother
all right thank you take care wilmington
you will me better guess anybody want to
go up next
uh um if you don't mind i'll be i'll be
uh very quick
so um i just i just wanted to uh i just
wanted to say that
um this was an individual who like me
and him like i think
that we both never looked eye to eye
to anything like period at every time
that we spoke but we always had a mutual
respect for each other
and an understanding of what we we
needed to do
for ilp and for for lognet and
i i will always say that he's always
going to be
the core of lognet because
we wouldn't be where we were without his
background knowledge and information
that he brought into us
and i will say that he he's a man that
i'll always have respect for i will
always miss
for sure for sure now i appreciate it
yeah
yeah like you said uh i remember those
messages petey didn't do
such such-and-such and i'm like oh my
god and i'm like if you tweeted this
but i do remember you know say a lot of
i remember i think it was the discord
creation and stuff like that
and i remember him he'd fight but then
he pulled me to the side
and he said okay i understand why why
petey did that okay
so he was always that push pull you know
hide knows what you're talking about you
have that push pull with him
and you gotta sometimes you gotta fight
back with him but then
at times he would actually concede and
say you know what no i do understand
why you did that so yeah salute man i'm
glad i'm glad you guys
the only sad part i have is that um in
reference to you guys
is that and myself is that we didn't get
a chance
because of covet to go to a show
together or
to do the things that we would do on the
show floor because
that was something he always told me
that he was envious of when
he would see me you and the guys whether
it be a pax or
whatever it was and he always wanted
to have that he's like doing when things
go down to texas yeah well you got
quakecon whatever
and that's the only regret because i'm
like our brother didn't get his chance
to do that while we we built you know
what i mean
yeah maybe we can do that in his honor
boys absolutely what's going on
currently talk to the people tell them
the amazing person you are your
relationship to our brother
all right well man hey i i appreciate it
i'm gonna hand it to chris cause chris
only had a couple of words
sure sure what's going on chris what's
up guys
um i'm uh i'm chris i'm reaper's
older brother for those of you who don't
know um i'm not really
like heavy in the community with you
guys and um but
i hear a lot about you all and i just
want to say thank you guys for for
holding this
um in his name um it's it's it's
much appreciated and um
it's really nice to hear all these
stories of how much he's impacted all of
you
and the person he is and that he doesn't
just pick fights with us
for the sake of picking the fight it's
nice no he does that with everybody
it's nice to see you thought she's gonna
feel bad too right yeah
well i mean it's it's nice to know and
i'm listening to everybody say this like
man he just
he just does it for the sake of doing
because like on the flip side he's
trolling other people too just like
getting you to go at each other
yes and uh you know there was a lot of
times especially in our family chat
where he would just go and i'm like you
know what i'm hitting you i i can't do
this
we fall victim i know yes he's just like
you know what i know what you're doing
i'm not doing and you'll even say it
you'll say it in the chat and
you still fall for it like damn you got
me yeah um
but he definitely was a fighter and and
you know i looking back on his life
and how we we met you know gaming was
definitely his calling
um you know i when i met him we were the
he was playing ultima online and i loved
that was the first first game that i
ever saw him play um
and you know then we went to you know
playing time splitters madden tycoon
roller coaster you know those are kind
of games we played the sims
i have a little funny story about that
when with the sims is we we hated
sharing the game
the games with our brothers and we
always stayed at his house
and um my mom was tdy so we were there
for this week and we
were just fighting over sharing the
stamps and such i actually wasn't
feeling well
and you know kevin's mom let me stay
home
and kevin all of a sudden he's like yeah
i'm not feeling well either yada yada as
soon as kevin's mom left that door
and walked to walk into her car he looks
at me and raised his hand like yes and i
was like what are you what
he's like we get to stay home and play
the sims all day
why i'm staying home but okay
so sure enough we were downstairs in the
basement plane taking turns playing the
sims looking out the little window of
the crawl space to see when mom got home
um but you know over all the years he
would always try to get me to play games
and i was always stuck on that
and and uh but um you know it was
definitely his calling and you know and
i couldn't be
happy happier and prouder of him you
know fine
finding you all and and building this
brand together and
and you know making a name and i
thank you all for for giving him that
platform and i'm proud of him for
allowing you guys to be a part of that
and i just thank you guys so much for
this it means a lot
thank you for being with us it means a
lot to you guys to be here
because we know how how close you guys
were
and um for you guys to appreciate that
and you know
we're honored that you know a lot of you
guys live with him day to day like
physically meeting him and and doing
these things and our daily interactions
you know i mean
as much as we appreciate them we
appreciate you you you guys
he brought you into but he connected
both worlds in a way
and um i thought that was cool because i
through him i got a chance to meet you
your brother and
you know i mean all these cool people
that we all share this story and it's so
cool to hear this i'm so glad you made
it
you know that's number one and um yeah
much appreciated brother
definitely for sure all right thank you
guys for having us on here and i'm gonna
turn it back to darnell we're actually
heading over to rose's and i know she's
watching
um so but thank you guys so much
and uh we'll talk soon of course we will
keep the communication we're gonna keep
his name alive too
darnell thank you brother yeah now i'm
glad chris was uh
able to speak and i'll try i'll try to
do what i do man i try to bring a little
bit of brevity
but hearing hearing all the stories man
it's just a common theme and i really
wanted to address the common theme man
like this this
has always been a fighter he's always
been
strong i mean you know uh me and his
moms were talking the other
yesterday like you know even when we
were playing football as kids he got the
he got the award for like having the
most heart
and it's just a testament to to dis i
mean he did
he never complained once about anything
like my man knew what he needed to do
when he needed to do it and he got it
done and um
you know i think we're all better people
for knowing him for that
and i just wanted to uh just bring some
of your guys stories together just so we
all can understand the context of
of everything that was kevin i've known
kevin since 1999 man
um and
you know actually i met kevin through
chris
seeing how it connects he's seeing the
dots yeah yeah cause i've known kristen
it's like you know chris was always a
grade younger than me and kevin
and i met chris when i was like in the
in the fourth grade
um and when kevin moved into town
some odd reason like i think i think you
guys were in a camp together or
something
um and then y'all became friends um
and then i was talking to kevin in class
one day and he was like
hey yo you uh you know this ellison cat
and i was like chris
i was like yeah chris is my neighbor man
nice boy and like ever since that's when
the trio came together
i mean like we were inseparable man it
was always me diz
and and chris um
people thought we were in a relationship
yeah
[Laughter]
it was it was bromance at first sight
you know
we all had so much in common you know we
we all enjoyed football
like we we loved we loved playing video
games and
we had we all had our different our
different taste in video games because
like chris was always like a sports
gamer
and he would play ultima and stuff uh
you know i remember when everquest
online was a thing
and
[Laughter]
how our setup was you know this this
always had the playstation and gamecube
right
because like you know he was a big
nintendo guy he loved nintendo
um me like you know i had i had a
playstation but i enjoyed my xbox more
uh you know i had a dream cast
but um like you know just to kind of
bring some of these stories together man
like i want to fast forward a little bit
so
um me and kevin both had aspirations
to join the air force yes um i was in
our i was in rotc
i'm at the college route um
kevin kevin decided that uh he wanted to
enlist
first uh get the college money and then
go
so um he he enlisted and
man like you want to talk about a world
changing immediately
two weeks before my man was supposed to
ship out
uh he was complaining about his leg
and he was like man like you know it
just doesn't feel right and i was like
bro
just suck it up like you know just just
just make
it down the basic and you know if you're
hurt
they'll take care of you while you're
down there you don't have to worry about
anything he's like nah man like
i just don't he was like it just really
hurts i want to go get this checked out
and um you know a little little known
story other than like you know chris
found out
but all these years like no one no one
ever knew that like my dad
my dad was a lab tech that actually
found
the the cancer cells in his body and my
my pops actually was the one that went
to the dock and was like hey we really
got a problem
um the doc wasn't sure because she she
she didn't think that that's what it was
at first because kevin was young
like you know we were 18 you know and
she was like you know because the x-rays
didn't really show much but
his blood work you know blood blood can
tell you a lot of things and
so like my dad didn't even talk to me
when he got home from work
so i knew something was up um
and he did he waited he waited until he
knew that the doc had already talked to
his moms and his stepdad
about the diagnosis and so you know i
remember
he sat me down and was like you know i
just wanted you to know that
um you know we we we we're we're not
conclusive but um you know
it's it's likely that kevin has cancer
so that's when um that's when he you
found out that he had lymphoma
i think that was what it was oh there it
is um in his leg
and like man what i mean i was like like
i was in college at the time and i
remember
like when he when he started his his
rounds of chemo
um man i was i was in the hospital up at
that that hospital because like you know
we were out at whiteman air force base
and his treatments were in kansas city
at ku
and i would drive back and forth back
and forth
um just to just to make sure my dude was
doing all right
you know like y'all keep talking about
his spirit bro
even in the hospital my man was just
like nothing was wrong
i must say though that when he was in
the hospital after
and i was up there after surgery we did
play madden and i really i beat him
like three times in a row and he's not
happy
because i remember he he'd hit me up and
he'd be like [ __ ]
um so the game pass app you got to tell
me how to get this x cloud going and i'm
just like yo ex clouded from the
for the room and he's like yeah then he
got the switch and he
made it his business that the gaming is
continuing
here continue sir oh yeah man and so
like
boys y'all didn't even get to see the
phase of kevin that
was just a delight so like
when the rate when when his enlistment
didn't work out like i enlisted
um i i i enlisted and i left in february
um he was going through the rest of his
treatments
i'm almost done man but you know he he
went through the rest of his treatments
and everything
um
and you know by the time i got back he
was out of the hospital he was walking
again
and my my man switched it up like uh i'm
telling he
he walked out like he was stuck you know
significant or something
[Laughter]
my boy was fresh i see the picture
i see them i see them all right little
little did i know he had he had uh he
had started up his little rap career oh
yeah that's what he was speaking that's
what he used to have the hip hop debates
with this continue
um you know
and that's when he really liked got into
writing and everything and
um he was going he was going to he was
going to school and everything and
you know i was like well you know the
radar technician thing didn't work out
what are you trying to do now
he's like you know i think i'm trying to
get the sports right
sounds like sports writing all right
that's cool and
you know and i remember that's when he
started to uh like
like uh do the blogging thing on myspace
uh
and like you know in a couple other uh
things
and he was just doing sports exclusively
and then like you know fast forward a
couple years he was like yo
d i get i got this idea i want to bounce
it off you and i'm like all right man
like let's hear it
he was like what would you think of
an independent like gaming community
and i was like you got my attention bro
i was like that sounds pretty cool he
was like yeah you know
he was like you know because at the time
like you know ig ign
and um all those other networks were
just
just becoming bigger right and he was
like you know
like we got these big these big gaming
networks but what about like
an independent community i was like okay
all right and um that's when the
playback
uh playback error oh yeah yeah
came the came to the fold and um
like i i just remember like you know and
uh he was just so ecstatic about it and
that's when he just got into this mode
of like
just collecting people collecting their
voices you know making sure that
everybody could be heard and so then we
uh then we started the uh
the the playback gaming uh our vlog
right
and you know at the time i was enlisted
like
i was drinking i had a mouth of like a
state a sailor
so he was like all right so he was like
i'm gonna still have you on but we're
gonna have to do uh playback after dark
fair enough
that's this yeah man
and i just remember like when you
brought on bella and a couple other
folks
remember that earlier oh yeah oh yeah
they got up to like
i want we got up to about 60 000 views
and then that's when the schism occurred
yeah uh everybody had their own ideas of
what direction to go in
him and bella kicked me out you know uh
for good reason like mine i i've got a
very business mindset and so i was like
yo man we're already at 60 000 views
i was like you know we can start talking
about monetization and everything else
and like y'all said
dudes was against clickbait oh yeah he
he fight two finale he'd fight me tooth
and nail with clickbait titles
or he would rather and i think ames
would appreciate this
he would rather a better story
than chasing the hot news so to speak
and
that was and i had to learn that from
him because i i didn't have
a website background so everything i
learned was through him
and i remember like no we got you know
this is news this is breaking we should
be on it and he's like
this is what we need to tell and i had
to fall back i learned that from him so
it's funny you said that
with you bumping heads with him on some
level with philosophy
but in the end he ends up being right
because you start learning because i
know you pushing the business side
demonetization i
know we used to have these conversations
you know and it's like he's like he's
standing on his square and we're like yo
but we need to win we need to make money
and we need to do it
we got to be separate and distinctive
and he
he stood on his square with that i'm
glad you brought that out brother
continue
continue um and so i was like all right
and he was like listen man like me and
bella talked
and again like this was his idea this
was his dream
and he was like you know we just don't
have the same ideas for modernization
everything else and i was like listen
bro like i'm always here for you
like that was you know kevin was always
my ride or die man
like me and him bumped heads many times
i mean you know there were things that
we saw eye to eye on
we had a lot more in common than we had
you know disagreements on
and i'm gonna miss those conversations
with them because like you said
my dude stood on his laurels and he was
always about trying to do what he
thought was
the right thing to do and you know the
the man he stands he stands tall on that
and i'm like you know just uh
just kind of bring it back to what y'all
were saying like you know yeah rose rose
is a strong woman oh my god because
my dude has strong opinions um but she
was
always there for him and you know like i
said i know she might still be listening
in
and i just want to tell the community
that
like when when he started talking about
rose
uh when when he was working at the olive
garden bro like i knew i knew what was
up yeah you do
you um it was like you know kevin kevin
and me
and chris we always talked about women
and
i could tell in his voice
that she was different to him and
you know even even even when they had
some disagreements like he
never ever ever once like said anything
bad about her
um you know he's just he talked about
how he and
how you know he might have been annoyed
with something but at the same time he
would always back that you know
to walk that back and be like you know
what maybe i was in the wrong
and you know the love that he had for
the gaming community
pales in comparison to the love that he
had for his wife yeah pales in
comparison to the love that he had for
his kid
and you know when when i remember kevin
these are going to be the things that
that i reflect on is just
the fact that he was able to live a life
that
he could truly love he loved
loved writing about gaming you know he
loved the fact that
um out of his relationship with rose
they have a beautiful son
um in that he had this beautiful
marriage
and his life did not materialize in the
way that
kevin wanted it to but he was able to
bring
all of us together look what he's done
to make the most of it
and craft a life that he was proud of
and that he was loved
you know there's just nothing but love
and that's all i get
my boys nothing but love because kevin
was a good man
and like you said you know um if y'all
ever in the future thinking about going
to a con and doing something
and we could do a little shout back to
kevin absolutely you know it would mean
absolutely as soon as the world gets
back to normal i'm down there bro
oh absolutely absolutely because at the
end of the day like my man's legend he's
it's gonna live on facts
um and like you were saying man he's
gonna be a lord forever forever
forever brother and i appreciate you man
because
especially both of you for coming on and
you know again you you guys knew him
best
you know and you have those real life
accounts and
you know we're honored that you you
showed up because
you know we we know what you guys are
going through this this reverberated
throughout the gaming community i can
only imagine what you guys went through
but for the gaming community this hit
so hard and but the positive was to see
all the stories and the interactions
that our brother
touched everybody everybody had a dizzy
story and then i
you learn stuff you're like wow you
didn't know this you didn't know that so
again salute
salute to rosloe to the family salute to
you guys i know you guys
have the the of the function tomorrow
send out blessings to the family and
everyone
and i'm glad you guys supported this
this this meant a lot to me because
i know you guys knew him best so thank
you brothers thank you you really mean a
lot
you already know i still need to put a
face to the name bro because
now we played many the gal you know what
i mean now we got the face to the name
you don't see it you already
know salute brother hank i see
hey thanks for having us thanks for
listening everyone you already know
yeah thank you guys thank you anchor
hey guys what's going on oh boy cow oh
cal i'm sorry brother are you um on cut
tiger straight cow because i know
i just want to make sure everybody gets
uh their timing yeah i just want to talk
a little bit man
i don't think i'm just getting a little
emotional it's okay brother
we know it this is tough man this is
tough but we gotta heal
celebrate his life yeah man i don't
think people
i mean i was sick when i got the news
and um i don't think people understand
the impact
does he have with me um
and a lot of the things that we did
together it's like
when you spend time with somebody every
day for like
a certain amount of time you start to
develop a relationship like even if
you've never seen
the person you start to develop
that friendship and um
i mean this guy i mean this guy
like literally made me experience an
entire genre and changed the way i
played games
[Music]
um you know we would play arc this guy
was a dedicated
art guy or
dinosaurs he would spend hours raising
dinosaurs and building and stuff we
would spend so much time together
playing that game i it was games that i
didn't play for years
because i was playing art so much and i
had to literally tell him i had to quit
i'll say yo i can't keep doing this like
yeah it's like crazy i'm like you know i
can't keep playing this but
you know he never gave up on trying to
get me to go and come back to the game
or
play something else this guy was like
king of survival games man
um you know it was it was crazy and then
what's even more spectacular this man is
so
unselfish because uh when i was
you know building the tick games network
and stuff like that he was a part of the
team
um you know playback gaming was pretty
much i guess you could say in a way done
it was kind of moving on from it but it
still existed
and um you know he was teaching me some
things about social media
and how to build things through that and
the man had
10 000 subscribers on the playback
uh facebook page and knowing that he
wasn't going to continue to use that he
literally gave it to me
selfless selfless self absolutely
selfless
and you know that helped us grow even
further he had such a
huge impact in what we did at tech
from you know helping us work together
um you know iop and tick at that time
and then
like you know just being there being a
writer thinking of ways to
improve what we were doing over there it
just was very impactful
yes to me and um i know that there was
times when he was like he couldn't
be consistent because of you know a
whole bunch of reasons and stuff like
that
and um you know but i never felt like
he didn't contribute i never felt like
you know this man wasn't impactful on
what we did
and um i think what hurts the most
is that there was a time
where we weren't talking i remember
and um you know and he sent me a message
you know he reached out he was he was a
man that
stepped up and sent me a message and
basically
apologized and squashed whatever he
might have been confused about
you know and we spoke about that and wow
you know the one thing he said to me was
like i should have came to you
and asked you first before making any
judgments and a lot of men don't do that
don't do that
in fact a lot of men don't do that a lot
of people stay
petty in their feelings and you know
they stay where they click or they
choose signs
but he didn't do that and you know once
we got past that
that friendship that we had was
instantaneous
hitting me up he was dming me asked me
if i was going to play rush trying to
get me back in the arc
we would have these conversations and
the last time i spoke to him directly in
the dm was like january 14th
you know and he was we were talking
about rust and
stuff like he was excited he was excited
about russ yeah yeah he was really
excited about rust
so you know it's just like finding this
stuff out
is very dramatic to me because i was in
the hospital for a minute myself
i'm sorry um like last year like two
years ago something like that and then
right after i came out he went in
you know so it's like i kind of
understood what he was going through
in a way and um you know i try to
communicate with him and
pray for him and wish him luck and stuff
like that and finding out that he had
ammonia
which was crazy because i literally just
saw him say i'm in the hospital i'm
bored as hell my wife just brought me a
switch
so i'm good to go you know and i'm like
okay you know and it just seemed
so crazy because after he said that
he kind of went quiet yeah yeah and i
didn't see nothing
from him no more yeah i just thought
that he would go in
and fight through it as he did with
cancer and come out and be okay
you know so you know i just you know i
just
just finding this out kind of hurt me in
a way because it's like
oh yeah like the time that we wasted in
between that
i feel you brother i don't know what i'm
saying no i know
it was worth it you you wasn't worth it
i'm glad you're here
because obviously you know i'm saying
the differences that you had
at that time with him i knew of you know
i mean and it was well documented
however i never knew you guys
rectified yeah and i'm so glad
that you were able to you know because i
like you said at the time
emotions were high tensions were high
right all of us
here were all connected to each other
through some way whether it be
playback tick iop law we know the
history right
right right but the fact of the matter
is i never knew
he did that i assumed it was still not
talking anymore so to see you guys be
able to do that
before and make things right that that
makes me that makes my heart
you know really feel good about that
situation and that
you can have peace with that because
like you said at the end of the day
life is too short bro you know what i'm
saying
we all share this thing that we love and
and i'm glad you made it because at the
end of the day i never knew that and
i would have never heard your story if
we didn't allow it so salute to you for
for coming through and pulling up and
celebrating our brother that means a lot
man
yeah no doubt man just you know i was
just when i look back at that whole
situation it's just like it wasn't worth
it it never is
and you you waste time in between those
things and
you think about all the year like i've
known this man for like four years
yeah you know what i'm saying and like
to be able to communicate get back to
where we were
and then have that kind of snatched away
really hurt
you know it really hurt a lot and stuff
i i was really too messed up for
you know like literally the whole day i
couldn't do it i felt sick
couldn't play no games yeah
i couldn't i just can't yeah i just i
just couldn't i just couldn't think
about that you know but
um you know but he was a he was a great
guy man he
basically uh was so supportive always
had my back i remember one time
he was playing arc and um his guy had
his guy had joined the
the crew or whatever and uh i remember
joining the party
right when his friend was going on some
type of racist tyrant
and it was awkward as hell because i'm
sitting in there and he's saying
something
and i'm like i remember this
[Laughter]
yeah i was just i just popped in the
party and he like everybody got quiet
cause i popped to the party
right and then so the guy left and then
me and him was just there like
what the hell just happened so um we
come back and
i guess the guy was playing with him
before i was playing with him he had
some dinosaurs
or whatever that uh he wanted to give
back and
diz was so mad that he literally took
uh like the safeties off all the
dinosaurs and
just killed every single one of his
dinosaurs including him you know what
i'm saying and i was just like wow that
was crazy you know
he knew this guy longer than me wow but
just just because of that you know he
did what he did and stuff and the guy
was all mad and pissed off he's like
crazy dinosaurs
and everything like that but this was
like f that you know what i'm saying
so i'll never forget that that time
playing and stuff like that and like
we've been through a whole bunch of
battles and rebuilding and
all types of stuff man he's you know
this guy was just
he was he was excellent man he was just
a cool dude
and uh i really really
want to send my condolences to his his
wife and his son
and i really wish that you know that
they grieve
peacefully and that they heal quickly
um and you know this was just
this was uh he's the man and i'm going
to miss him appreciate you about well
said
well said hank i know you want to go
so
i've known this a good long time at this
point
you are the dot connected with all of us
here
yeah with the exception of uh reaper and
colonel
and all the rest of them i think they
know him longer than i did
but um i've known
this for about years um i remember
because i started my youtube channel and
he was one of the first people that
contacted me
jumped at a party and we started talking
we really hit it off people don't
realize
how connected dizzy was to
everything i know he worked on
rgm or real game media when that was the
thing so he had been working with sam
for a little bit
mm-hmm um he's not only had that he had
his own website
he would play back he worked on tick he
worked on iron lords and log net
he's worked on so many different people
he's been working for every single team
and he did not take sides on that kind
of regard he
if he saw you and he cared about you he
would put in the work
to make it happen no matter what it was
um there's i mean there's a lot of
things i could talk
about um i'll i'll tell you
this is a story that would pop in
because for me i would have waves of
hanging out with lots of different
people so i would
like oh i'll spend a couple months with
these guys over here then i'll go over
with these guys for a couple months but
i would always come back
and just kind of go with that cycle um
dizzy was in that
that cycle there and i would try to talk
to him at least once once a month at
least if we weren't talking on a regular
basis
um uh one period i just uh
graduated i had just gone to e3 and
that's why i bet you guys uh in person
at least
um i had come back
and i was slowly with my parents i
remember because
i had crappy internet and i remember
um that's when dizzy got me to play arc
oh right now you got you got you got
fought at the brainwashing too
damn it yeah i mean i i played arc
i have played arc a couple of times but
i never played it like in depth
um dizzy convinced me like hey i'm gonna
do a primitive plus server
we're gonna have these guys and we're
gonna we're gonna be the number one
uh we're the alpha try but we're gonna
we're gonna control everything
so here it's like space already picked
out and so i started playing and i
remember we
i had played with him for about three
months and not playing any other game
but arc every single day that goddamn
game
i i remember playing that game and like
oh just doing
doing dumb things like going up to the
the winter zone on the island map and
just
trying to get mammoths and rg's and just
random things like that
but the member the memory that always
comes up but every time i joined the
party and he was trying to convince
somebody to play arc
every time i would join a party with him
this is the story he would tell
let's go and this is the story out every
single time
let's go on the server we had agreed
that we wanted to do a raid
and so there was one particular clan
that we did not like and it was navy
um navy had like maybe like five or six
guys they had a big fort like maybe
about
a couple miles away from us um they had
just kind of been trolling for a while
so we just decided as a group we wanted
to take them out so the
the rest of the server that we launched
this giant server-wide
uh wipe attempt against them i think so
i remember because like dizzy and a
couple other guys
they were kind of like they were in
charge of okay here's what we're gonna
do for this offensive here here's where
we're gonna attack and go through this
whole process
so navy had created an alliance with a
group called farmers and they were using
farmers base to kind of restock and go
back to the fight and launch a flank
offensive
on the rear of the teams that were
trying to attack the front
so what was going on
we're going to respawn at this one
particular location it was a long house
it had a bunch of walls and a bunch of
doors
if you haven't played arc it is a pain
in the butt to destroy
any building especially at that time it
took
it would take hours to destroy a
building so we didn't bother doing that
so dizzy assigns me and him
to take out this one base just the two
of us
because it's just a long house by itself
but they were this is the point that
they were reinforcing it
so we go over to this location
um and he's in an rg and i'm decked out
in like plate armor
and i got like a pike and a couple
weapons on me we're like all right we're
we're gonna get him as soon as they open
the door
we were there for about three hours we
killed maybe
20 30 people and just he and i and we're
just like having we're just laughing up
a storm
like what would happen is as soon as
they open the door i'm like trying to
pike them just try to stab them as fast
as i possibly can if they if there were
two of them and they got one got past me
he'd pick him up in the rg and drop him
to their death
[ __ ] every time i have we're just
bawling laughing having a great time
we played until like maybe about four in
the morning i had to go to work in like
three hours
uh we had so much fun playing that game
and i just that's the memory i remember
of him and he and i just having the best
time possible
and we're just cracking just talking
stuff but we talked about personal
things a lot
um we talked about like finances
dealing with stuff um
there's just so much stuff and he helped
me out quite a bit through a lot of
really tough times
and i just i owe a lot to him
let's see the thing about dizzy is that
we all knew that
he liked survival games um like whether
it was ark
conan whatever he loves survival games
because he could find out the rules
about that yes
but the thing was he was always playing
his own game of survival and this
i think he found solace in the survival
games in particular because he could
always find out the rules
and how to win good point he was dealing
with
his own [ __ ] in his own game of survival
no brother you said it well you said it
well i mean
i didn't even think about that
connection and and his love
for that genre you know it was it it
makes sense too
you know but i remember i mean when
anything would come in
you know survival he was on it he'd be
like [ __ ] you know i'm the first to grab
that with a review or
i'm like brother i'm not even gonna
fight you because you are the
connoisseur
of that genre and and that ark story i
do remember
i do remember this big war between this
rival clan
and it was a big thing and i do i
remember hearing that story
actually you're right that would be the
recruiting pitch to anyone who was
interested
in ark because they would be like yo let
me tell you you could have these crazy
battles and he would go on and on and
shout out i want to shout out big bad
john i want to shout out chief tommy's
in here a lot of the people that's in
the clan
his art clan i mean you guys got to get
together to figure out
how to keep this thing alive for him and
because i know for a fact
that meant a lot to him so thank you
thank you for the anchor um aims and i
know
clowns you guys have been here the
longest i want to be respectful because
i know you guys have been here very long
so so i think mahmood said he wanted to
go next okay so please go ahead i just
took the rest of the day off so
oh okay i just went i didn't know my
brother locked it in the building
bahrain
appreciate it you know yeah no worries
man yeah
it's almost eleven o'clock here at night
so uh i'll try to be
short um i've always been uh
like uh really into video games for
mohawk live one the first games i ever
played was contra
so i've always had like uh a willingness
to write about video games and so when i
i delved around here and there and and
such but um
it's when i actually joined lognet that
i really felt appreciated and part of
that
not only appreciate about being part of
a community and
part of that was you know was cog it was
also with um
dizzy as well and this was always you
know
he would get excited about weird things
with me for some reason like when we
when he decided to give me like a log
net email and i was like he's like
you're getting a log that email i'm like
okay
that's great you know it's a big thing
yeah yeah it is
and uh you know i went away for a few
months because you know i have two
little kids you know you saw my daughter
here before so
yeah i apologize about that but um i
i couldn't stay out of log net for long
you know i i wanted to have that
connection especially now with covet
and the way things are going and um i
felt connected to longman in such a deep
way and part of that was it was dizzy
and
there was actually one moment i remember
that i was just playing xbox one day and
uh
and i saw dizzy playing division two and
i know you guys love destiny and
believe me i played a fair share of the
destiny by division two just you know
it cost you more doors oh lord
don't encourage them y'all encourage you
what can i say and so like uh
and i saw jesus playing division two on
xbox i'm like yo
can i join in with you he's like yeah
yeah of course but you know
being in the middle east and you know in
america obviously so
servers didn't didn't really talk to
each other the right way but uh even
though like
i didn't get to play with them you know
we chatted on xbox chats and you know
how terrible it is you know
we did we chatted for a good 40 minutes
just like well just random stuff about
games and stuff like that and that
i know it's nothing big compared to like
some of the other stories we heard right
now but
it just goes to show you that dizzy
would always uh
have tried to have a meaningful
conversation with anyone really and
that uh passion that he has and that
commitment to
to games you know it really he it really
blew
through for him you know and um you know
i i give my condolences to his wife to
his child
and uh that's that's and we're gonna
miss him we're gonna miss you dizzy you
know you really touched me in ways that
i never thought possible all right well
thanks for hearing me out
my mom thank you for making it brother
um just to double down on your story
with the email so you know
is that um you know i remember having
talks with dizzy
and we again we're doing our little
fantasy football
lining up all the writers who's the guys
you know like
the talent that we have and you know i
remember
he made it up like he really made it his
business to say okay
these are the guys that need to get
emails first
right and i remember you know your name
came up and your name came pretty fast
because i mean we kind of at that time
had like
you know you got to wait a three to six
month kind of thing and you know what
i'm saying then kind of earn your
stripes and kind of thing and he's like
boys ready and i was like okay and
usually i'm the guy that's trying to
push things further and he's put
he's stopping me but i remember with
your name specifically
he was uh no no because it was one of
those things where he always says
it's a joy to edit your article it's a
joy
it's certain writers we were like it's a
joke because it wasn't no work you're
just like oh my god this is
like aids understands as a website owner
you know and seo and all that and you're
like damn it's double green and it's
like there's not much i got to do and
you know you got your grammarly or
whatever your checks on and just to
check grammar and structure but
you know there was really not much that
he had to do
and that was one of the things he always
said about you and i want to shout out
if he's not here
gondor you're another one you know what
i'm saying that
again um he daniel may danny
if he's here get gondor's condo
affectionately to us in log net
but um you guys he he he you were on
that
dizzy draft pick side like yesterday
like he's my god you see
you see [ __ ] you said i'm like yo you're
right i go front whatever i go to their
articles when it's my turn
to edit it's it's light work so it'll be
a pleasure when you guys have something
okay again not the rest of the team was
hard to deal with but just to see
the fact that what you said about the
email thing
that was him and he he had respect and
when
i i got the chance to tell him because
we all knew you had the the child
and and shout to lord lord khalid you
know what i'm saying but um
you know one thing he said i was able to
tell him i was like
you know boys coming back and he i was
able he was so happy because he was just
like okay
in the editorial role we're in good
hands you know so
we're going to keep that vision alive
for our brother so salute to you for
making it
and shut much love much love man
aims clowns i know you guys have been
here too so i just want to be respectful
for you guys as far as i can go or if
you want to go
i have no preference man um
all right i guess i'll go so
wow this i mean i'm gonna probably
jumble my words a little bit because
um i like dizzy a lot and
i'm gonna miss him for sure with dizzy
my story is a little bit different i
never argued with them because we always
agreed together
and we like to uh tease people together
especially um you know we see
this brotherhood it posts something
about destiny
uh and i'd be like yep that's the
destiny you know
i would do it all the time and then he
would back me up i'll
back him up oh it was so much fun i'm
gonna
i'm gonna miss that man and he used to
come into the the 4g
uh quarters rooms and you know he never
criticized us
um he always like seemed to like what we
talked about he never
had any issues about our format uh
he always i knew he always wanted to
come on the show from way back in the
day
um from way back with the old panel that
i used to have um
well and i i remember when he first
started up with uh
helping out with um you know lognet
i have never forgotten about all that
because the
the old panel was like oh you see these
these moves that are being made it's
uh this guy dizzy he's a you know he's a
good guy he's a solid guy and
uh even though i don't get along with my
whole panel anymore uh it was always
like
positive uh talks about dizzy like
amongst everybody everybody had positive
things to say about dizzy because dizzy
was the kind of guy
that can make things happen um
and make things better he would and like
everybody else said that he was a very
selfless guy
and i remember when i found out that he
was going through cancer
and i forgot how i found out i don't
remember if it was through you know
talking to you
um cog or you know somebody else in in
disney circle but
i messaged him i'm like man how you
doing he's like oh i'm doing fine how
about you
like it was like nothing yep like
nothing man like this
this guy like you know i was like man i
wish i could be strong like this dude
sometimes because
nothing seemed to bother him at least
you know he never showed it
and uh you know it definitely was a
tough bottle what he was going through
and it
i know that it's not an easy battle
because we've seen other people go
through similar battles and
they don't take it as well as dizzy did
dizzy
dizzy was like a really strong man he
was a fighter
and uh i mean i remember
[Music]
i remember when he got coveted i was
really worried because
my mom went through you know she had the
the rare cancer too
and then she got covered and then my mom
almost died
and um you know the the hospital she was
in saved her
i got covered right after her and i was
about to go into icu like in two days my
doctor said if i didn't take an
experimental treatment that saved my
life
and i remember when disney got covered i
told him man i'm like
dude i'm really worried about you like
this
is this is some pretty serious stuff and
he's like no man i'm i'm good don't
worry about it
he's like i'm going you know i'm in the
hospital
they're taking good care of me i was
like uh and i i joked with him a little
bit and i
said man you gotta make sure that
doctor's taking good care of you because
you know i was thinking to myself maybe
i need to come up there and say
something to the doctor
but he's like no you know they're
following protocol
he's like it's it's crap you know he
used a couple other words but he's like
his crap being here
but uh he's like they're pretty good so
i feel confident
i was like well that's glad to hear it
and i remember the next day i asked
someone's like how about the food
are they giving you good food is it
gourmet food he's like no all this stuff
is crap
this is just crap
and uh you know i remember
i messaged him on on friday
and i was like so how you doing man and
he's like i'm hoping to be out here by
monday
the last i heard from i feel you brother
right yeah similar similar story
similar story um you know for me my
hospital communication
with him is similar to how your
communication with him through twitter
and uh
mines was facebook message so for me
the hope would always be when i would
see
the online status indicator
that he was awake
and prior you know i remember him going
in i remember the diagnosis
and you know one thing he's very
protective of is logged in on the back
end
so when i had conversation when he had a
confidence he's like
we need to talk i need to start handing
you some stuff over
and it hit me and i said hey what's
going on and it was the covid
diagnosis at that point like when he
told you
so um dizzy's very protective so for him
to
even mention that subject i knew the si
the severity
and the only other time we had the
conversation by handing everything over
was when josh was here
about you know when he first got
diagnosed with cancer and i was like wow
for him
to to to want to relinquish that to
joshua at the time was a little
contentious
with it from from an editor-in-chief
standpoint you know was one thing so
when this happened
i'm like okay but i told him i said
brother you know
one i'm not locking you out things will
remain the same
and because i know he would always view
things remotely he always found the way
and uh yeah it it the same way clowns it
hit me in that respect because i
i i sent my last message to him
was every time
every time i see your light on it gives
me hope
and i didn't see him through you know
that's the only thing that that really
got me so
i feel what you're saying brother
because uh those are the things i i held
on to as well
but um i'm glad that uh
he he knew that he was loved by the this
man is a fighter
this man is just his strength
personified
and you know i'm so glad that he found a
home uh with you guys
at iron lords because you are all
selfless as well
and i think that really fit you know
dizzy's character and
you know he like he liked to uh
pull some stuff on king every now and
then get him you know risen up and
i you know it was a home for him man and
um
you know there's a there's another story
it's not a long one but
um i remember the first time i actually
ever talked to him in voice
was anchorman had come is either angry
man came to my party or invited me to
his i don't remember exactly which one
it was
um but i was playing uh jurassic world
evolution anchorman was on fallout
76 and dizzy was in there and um
does he start talking and they were
actually joking around about barbecue as
well
maybe a recurring topic with that always
barbecue
and i you know i said oh i said uh you
know florida probably has better
barbecue than texas and disney's like
what
he's ready no i remember what he said
everybody said he said florida has
barbecued he's so disrespectful
and then i you know i joked back and
forth with and i'm like no you're
probably right i said because it's
probably not even sanitation to say it
because you
can find the barbecue on the side of the
road
but you know uh i'm gonna miss him man
and uh you know i i will honor him
with the uh the destiny teases and the
destiny killers
you know i'm never gonna be right if you
did
i'll always be there for that man it's
like god you know god bless him
um his family and uh
i just i i really feel for uh for rose
yeah for parker and rose because
i i i wasn't as young as parker
but i lost my dad early yeah i know
and uh it's tough
parker is gonna have a very hard time
so i hope that all of us here in the
gaming community
and i hope that all those i know dizzy
in real life that's close to the family
i hope as parker gets older in some way
or somehow
we can all give back and
be like a father to him because
the hardest thing to do is lose a pair
and now in essence
in the world i grew up in parker is now
the man of the house
even though he's as young as he is and
that's uh
it's a really tough spot to be yeah so
my thoughts and my condolences
with the family well sad brother once
said and uh
we definitely i know i i relayed the
message to rose and um
everything you said we re i reiterated
and um
we have to be there for her and and
parker during this tough time and they
have to know
that anything they need to us to lean on
we're there she's a gamer herself you
know
she's a big eso fan and there's always
reminding me you know about esl
we always talk everybody don't you
forget yes oh you take out a huge
community
he was shout out he shout out rosalind
and and parker you know he's going to be
a gamer he's born into it
but at the same time everything you said
uh clowns
resonates because this this child has
lost his father
at a young age and we can't lose sight
of that and this
this this this wife of his who was a
ride or die
wife they got married during the peak of
a lot of his
you know what was going on in his life
and um i know how much he loved his
babies i loved much he loved her that
was his best friend
and um we're gonna be there as a
community that's why we did this today
you know for the gaming community to
show
we could stand up put all our
differences aside all you know
to to show support for a man that pretty
much connected all of us in some way
so salute to you clients that hit that
every hit different so um
yeah um uh aims and uh forte
he's still got you guys up man i'm gonna
be respectful for you too
or today no preference matter i can go
where you can go
you mute it i think yeah you made it
forte
yeah we carry let's get you going it
doesn't show him you did it doesn't show
him
so maybe it's a mic mute yeah cause he's
still muted i'm not hearing them
yeah well maybe you got to maybe yeah
yeah i
i can go why you work that out for today
i'm not going to be super long um
uh yeah so it's it's been really
something listening to all these stories
um i didn't know him one of the reasons
i
also i didn't speak up early i didn't
know him as well as a lot of people here
today so
uh you know being respectful to the
people that really went back with him
um the funny thing is is hearing all
these uh
all these people talk about uh debating
with dizzy
because um i i think one other person
said it but i
i never did guys are always on the same
goddamn page
i always remember yeah yeah i mean i i
met him i think uh
early last year while earlier on i was
going through our messages just
scrolling back through and reading and
um he reached out to me first about
sg uh and just uh he had ordered some
shirts
and uh he he just said you know just
always love what you guys do and he's
just a huge huge proponent
and uh he he just talking to me offline
and i
you know the it's you hear the gaming
community a lot of people just come
together and have cool stories and uh
the way they meet and uh i had never
really met him i've never met him in
real life and yet
you touched on it earlier kog that there
was an appreciation for
uh what you and i always talk about the
heart of the gaming community
and this industry and what it's meant to
guys like us who have been around for a
long time and
and were gamers when it wasn't cool to
be a gamer
um and uh we we shared a lot of that him
and i talked back and forth
and um we developed this kind of
friendship where
we we didn't go back and forth we didn't
tease each other online
we brought up mass effect once in a
while yeah final fantasy 6 but
you know all that's effective and our
dms and stuff it was just
it was pure kind of respect and it was a
different
type of relationship we talked about how
outlets were managed in their work
you know what i mean we talked about
what was going on in the gaming industry
one of the last conversations we had was
a corporate thing about microsoft you
know he just he lived and breathed at
all
um and uh i just always appreciated that
because that's the way my mind works and
maybe that's why we hit it off the way
we did is because i we
it's just you see it a different way um
and uh you know i realized as we were
just kind of going
uh through us here that i've been
listening to everyone so intently i
didn't even plan out what i wanted to
say
um rather let it flow
uh you know clowns just really hit me
pretty hard without the problem yeah
with rosie
and uh parker and uh obviously don't
know them well but
uh i do know about loss um
oh yes and loss is uh you know it's
something um
your son one of the most powerful
articles i've ever read that's how
i found you was that article uh you're
losing your son
so i'm so glad you're here yeah it's um
it's uh you know i think the thing about
loss right even with someone like dizzy
who
uh was going through what he was going
through is
you can't prepare for it um
you know even even if and you never do
especially with someone like dizzy who
has everyone already covered you know
you wouldn't even never know when he was
going through what he was
but um you don't
you can't prepare for how it's going to
hit you when loss happens
um and so i was
going back through messages uh as
everyone was talking earlier and uh
it's kind of crazy we were talking about
something him and i just going back and
forth and
normal day and you know he was upbeat
and i'm
passionate um about what we were talking
about and i said you know
uh be real with me for a second you know
how are you doing
you know how how how's things going this
is only a little while ago
and uh he wrote it was a long paragraph
and he told me the details of like his
last couple weeks and i read it and i
was just like
holy hell man you know what i mean like
to show everyone's already said it i
know i'm just echoing
what people have said but to to
understand the details of what he was
going on
uh he was going through behind the
scenes
which nobody would know if uh
if you didn't know you know what i mean
um or didn't talk to him it was just
incredible and it it speaks to his
character
um the first word when i heard this news
and i saw your post which
messed me up i was i was in the middle
of a work meeting on camera
and you know we're working from home so
i'm i'm looking at twitter while i'm on
camera and i saw your message and uh
i i went off camera and i messaged my
boss and i said hey i'm going to be
i'm going to be kind of out of it for a
bit um
because i just he was genuine you know
it's the first word that came to my mind
as he was genuine he would tell you what
he thought he was sharp
he wouldn't back down but he also at the
same time managed to be all that without
being disrespectful yes
um and it's just there's something
special about him you know like i said
to not having ever met him in real life
and not even knowing him that long but
to consider him the way i do
um and for him to have touched me the
way he has
speaks to his character oh yeah um
and so you know what struck me as
everyone's talked over the past we've
been talking for three hours you know
and i'm sure we could keep going for a
long time
is it's been an echo chamber of um
of of what he meant to so many people i
mean look at the turnout in the chat and
the community and everything we've seen
i mean this is someone 90 probably five
plus percent of these people have never
met him in real life yeah
you know what i mean um actually there's
just there's something about that and it
this type of situation always brings
perspective i think fawns was talking
about it earlier which is like uh and
salomon was too there's or braf excuse
me enrique was talking about it where
it's just
there's no time for the um the debates
and the nonsense and the stuff people
find themselves
getting involved in on a daily basis
it's not worth it man
no um there's many much more important
things to
uh to enjoy and to
take advantage of while we have what we
have in front of us right here
so i could go i could go on for a while
but uh he just
yeah he he was a very special person
even in the short time i knew him we've
obviously heard
from people who knew him better that i
didn't misread that he was a very
special person
and um very very sorry to hear about his
loss and so i think it goes without
saying that
this whole community all of us here and
and who have had to go
will do whatever we can to help it
anyway
so appreciate you brother um yeah and to
uh
to rosian parker please be strong
um and uh know that even though you
don't really know us
you got a lot of awful lot of support if
you need it so factual
yeah man i mean definitely uh aims you
your words hit hard
you know he um you know again i told you
this before
you know with the foundation of lognet
he has such a respect for you you know
and and it was like
the way he looked at you and season
gaming and
you know was like a template of how to
do things the right way
you know and it was funny listening to
you guys talk about his
pure hatred for clickbait because i
think that's uh
i think that's what made him reach out
to me originally um was you know i think
i was going on one of my rants
you know and uh i think he just reached
out to me and was like yeah you got this
man
like uh yeah and uh it's crazy how
something like that of all things
can bring people together yeah yeah he
he had a special respect and um
i remember again like again because
being dizzy everything is a sports
analogy everything is a competition
so we sizing up the game right we're
like log net all right you know what's
it and then again
we get he's like yeah i ain't gonna
front season gaming man sometimes i get
envious of
the stuff they're doing and he's like he
said but in a good way because he was
like
yeah yeah you do we've had that
conversation yeah yeah
again doing it the right but the beauty
of him and i you know
but darnell said it you know yeah we
always say selfless
yes but again in this
content creator space in this website
space the rarity is
offering help to someone who technically
people look at oh that's your competitor
or you know you're not supposed to you
know that's vlog that i see they're not
supposed to you know what i mean
and he never adopted that that is where
i
know for example is we've had this
conversation yeah many times
remember this like oh
oh no we ain't going to help him we're
not you know i'm saying like all that
follower garbage and
i'm bigger than this person i can't help
that person and he he
subscribed to none of that and he didn't
put up with it he didn't put up even
like he didn't like it he didn't put up
with it he didn't put up with it and
you know fame said it best too because
um again
helping level one gaming get off the
ground right
again selfless where they they don't do
that they don't make people like that
anymore everyone is so
holding on to what they want you know
and and not trying to help
anyone else or or offer advice you know
and that's what i like and to your point
you know what's important
you know forget all this competitive
stuff forget all this
being disrespectful to each other you
know he he he didn't embody that he
embodied
a community and it shows for the turnout
so i thank you
for for saying that because uh yeah and
thanks for uh inviting me on man it's
been humbling because there's
some people out here who obviously knew
him extremely well in real life or for
years and years and so it's humbling to
be uh included so thanks absolutely
my brother forte yo you hear me now yes
sir yeah
you know you gotta you gotta refresh the
the mixer and stuff every once in a
while
you know how this tech is man you know
how this tech is sometimes but
yo man just all this proof to me
is is what i knew in the beginning when
i first met dizzy
that no matter who you are how long he
knew you
he was always going to be that person
that was going to treat you with the
same exact way that he treated everyone
else if he took the time out of his day
to spend time or just talk to you
that meant a lot because you know
knowing not knowing exactly what was
going on and you know because [ __ ]
you know share things with me tell me
what's going on and stuff
and he wouldn't say a word about it you
know i would have to like dm him and say
yo
how are you doing and the first thing
that really hit me was you know me being
a store manager at gamestop whenever
those articles would pop
up that they closed in four or five
hundred stores he would dm
he's like yo how's how's it going is
everything good with you
and i'm like i'm good and i said what
you're talking about he'll dm me a
a a link of a of an article and i'm like
oh no man
my store is good and i was like in my
mind i'm like this
i've never had a face-to-face
conversation with this person
about anything like that and all he
cares about is my
family and my well-being and making sure
that everything's going on with me and
um right in there i just truly knew the
type of person that we had in our life
and
um it's super unfortunate to know that
i won't get a chance to you know
reach out to him once again like i've
always did i didn't get the opportunity
because i was going through
my fight with colburn over the course of
the last couple of weeks and
hearing that he was going through it
really
really hit home for me because i
wouldn't wish this on anybody and
especially a person that i know is
already in a compromise situation and
i just i miss the conversations i miss
the back and forth um in our
fantasy football league next year is
going to be kind of crazy for me because
every year this man would just bring up
some crazy
narrative about how he barely lost to me
or he'd be
oh my god the fantasy football oh my
goodness
i remember i remember the last time we
had a really big conversation about this
i was at the beginning of the it was
like four weeks in i was three and one
i sent out a a text message i'm not a
text i send out a tweet
and i say look who's at the top of the
eastern division dizzy
three and one who's at the top dude
where are you at one and three
you're so competitive it did all dizzy
just said
oh he said that's okay where's your one
loss come from i was like
still you still said that one and three
then here comes josh ready
saying wait a minute hold up all i see
is a bunch of people arguing when i'm
number when i'm first
placed in the whole league and i'm like
oh lord here we go and i was about to
bury josh ready right in there and i was
like you know what that's just ready let
me leave him alone
salute to that lord's a football fantasy
league building
spice talk so much
so much back and forth about everything
and uh he used to leave me alone when it
came to the whole destiny thing because
i used to always say listen
the moment you talk bad about destiny is
the moment i'm going to talk about your
geriatric um running around dynasty
oh my god i said i wish you would bring
up anything bad about destiny you want
to sit up there and nurse a dinosaur for
15 hours
he left he left me alone when it came to
destiny
don't let me see you out here bad
talking destiny you and clouds can have
y'all back and forth about this whole
the destiny killer stuff but just make
sure when you talk to me about it
you be respectful because you and that
freaking dinosaur game is tired
i don't know what the heck this game
shout out to because i did end up
downloading i was just just like ad he
was talking about right now
reluctantly i downloaded this game he
indoctrinates you to play it
that's the bad thing about it but he
finally got me to download the game
he gave me the pitch just like he gave
everybody else about you know i said
whoa you could literally just have
like complete like go against other
clans in this game
okay i'm gonna download this game and
this is just when we get to
i got my just get the brand new xbox
series x and i'm already up here
complaining that
the hard drive space is only 800 gigs
after
after the initial install and i'm like
how much does this game go take
132 gigs you're already cursing them on
the way in
yeah i'm not going to play this game
longer than two weeks
why am i downloading this just just
download this
download the game all right dizzy i'm
about to download this game and that was
about three weeks ago
and uh i i'm very it's very unfortunate
i get a chance to
play with him in that ecosystem because
i know how much he loved
that part of his life and really
listening to people talk about why he
probably gravitated to that because
of his survival instincts of the type of
person that he was and the things that
he was battling
it was like for him that was like a game
literally a game of life playing that
type of game
and i think a lot of people just truly
don't understand
how we were so blessed
as a community to have him as a part of
our
lives like i said him
taking the time me and slomo
i know a lot of people especially like
people in this chat they know who we are
but we're we're
in all reality we're nobody but dizzy
treated us like somebody
he treated us with a respect that
nobody else truly did on the back end
outside of the people that we know in
this room or in this community
we had him on our show he did a
four-hour live stream
talking about the game awards and you
know dizzy got a lot of stuff going on
in his life
the fact that he was he was willing to
speak he was like yo how long do we got
you for he said yo just however long you
want to be
hey i'll be here as long as y'all need
me mm-hmm i was like [ __ ]
it's like you know i'm just happy i was
able to spend
that moment with him yeah because it
just
proved to me that in the end
the specialness of every person is the
in every individual is something we need
to cherish
and i'm just heart broken for his family
yeah because i have two little kids i
have a wife
and trust me me going through this whole
situation over the last couple like the
last couple of weeks
it scared me it scared me to
the bottom of my soul knowing that yo
make sure you're taking care of this and
make sure you're taking care of that
because i'm not typical person that's
going to reach out to just tell
everybody what's going on because
i don't feel like i want to burden
people
and i know that's how dizzy felt about
his situation he just wanted people to
know like hey i'm here
if i'm here talking to you then
everything is fine yeah
and that's the one thing that i'm gonna
miss the most about him so
i'm just happy that these stories um
are something that everybody can just
resonate with because
overall he meant so much to so many
different people
in so many different ways it's not one
thing that dizzy did
that made people feel like you know
that's just
how dizzy is it was multiple it's a
multitude of things
from the people that he knew in his
personal life to people that he only
knew for six months
[Music]
and i only know dizzy for about a good
two years and the two years i spelt with
dizzy is
two years that i will literally and
utterly not
forget and i'm just sad i didn't get a
chance to shake that man's brother that
man's hand
at some event coming up like i was going
to be able to do last year when all that
was taken away from us when this whole
thing
started so we would have all missed aims
all of us we have all met that we were
all
it wasn't for the pandemic dizzy was
coming did he say he had he said cog i'm
ready to go
you know and that that's that's the
regret i went with you too here brother
because
yeah so that's the only thing i i got to
say i just the one last thing i'll say
is everybody just
this is only the beginning of everything
for all of us
dizzy's story isn't over by any means
we're all going to share
everything that we need to share about
disney on a consistent basis
all the time and we're going to make
sure that we um
celebrate the life of this man not just
today and tomorrow but
as long as we are just a part of this
community and beyond
and just remember we have to cherish the
people that are here right now
guard the people that are closest to you
right now because
as much as this sucks right now there's
other people out there
in this community right now that we
communicate on a day-to-day basis
don't forget to tell them how much you
care about them because
i didn't get a chance to tell dizzy how
much he meant to me before this time
because you always think you got time
so remember that's the one thing that's
the most important thing
well said brother and uh yeah he he
loved you guys
he loved you guys and again you know you
you two provided therapy you know you
and slow
for him you know he he people don't
realize that the podcasting
that helps a lot of people you know
especially people going through stuff
just to be able to separate
the pain that's going on in their real
life and to be a part
of a community you know what i mean and
i i
always remember him saying about you
guys you know i got to get in there i
got to mess with him you know what i'm
saying i got to get in there i got to
play
he loved the content you know and he he
didn't mess with anybody that he didn't
respect
and he always always had love for you
man so
i'm definitely glad you said what you
said because it resonate it resonated
for sure
i see um my boy jay barry i see you in
there
you might be muted i know he was he's a
huge fan of you brother
i remember the food talks and stuff and
yeah totally
right you know saying that you came and
pulled up man so jay barry bad talk
talk about our brother man can you guys
can you guys hear me yeah you
crystal crystal clear okay cool yeah
sorry about that earlier
you know i was in here earlier but you
know work stuff meetings and
and all that jazz but i was listening in
the background and it's just great to
hear
you know everybody's stories with dizzy
uh
because it's it's kind of it's kind of
weird how we kind of met i think i met i
met dizzy through
uh through your podcast um to iron lords
but i was always confused of like why is
this guy always so nice to me
you know normally you know i would get
oh jay barry's in here oh we gotta block
him more yeah
damn playstation guys invaders
we gotta get him out of here you know
and uh it's multiple times where
dizzy would just dm me okay you know
there's times i'll come into the you
know look um i
lost chat you know i'll say what's up to
you guys bother king david
and keep it moving uh but disney would
he would dm me and be like hey man yo
i don't i won't let nobody disrespect
you in the chat somebody came in the
chat try to disrespect you
i couldn't have that i'm like you don't
got to do that you don't know me like
why are you doing that and yo ever since
that
like we really like i can really call
dizzy dizzy a friend because
they a comic book would come out disney
would hit me up your bar did you read
this yet like yeah let's go let's talk
about it
we're going debates about uh doom and
magneto all the time
because yeah i i love doom as well i
know he's a doom
oh x-men funny you said that though he
loved both
equally he he we will we go we'll go
dave's talking about x-men it's crazy
it's crazy and how
because i i'm all over the place i'm
sorry too man cuz this this my dude man
like uh normally when it comes to this
internet stuff i don't really open up a
lot to
you know to meant to many people like
you know people just know me for like
gaming stuff you know i keep it
i i keep it gaming i don't do the
personal stuff as much as people you
know paint a picture about i don't know
personal stuff for none of that right
and i always like to just keep that that
that that closed wall
you know that wall like all right it's
just gaming leave it alone but yo disney
yo i i'll be honest with you my man he
he broke through that wall he he he kept
punching that wall he was like nah nah
nah
nah it's this is not gonna happen yeah
yeah yeah i know you forgave me but
yo you're a cool dude man a lot of
people don't know you're a cool dude and
i'm just like why is this guy so nice
man like this dude is just amazing
real talk after all the stories i'm here
like real really and truly
dizzy isn't is an amazing person man and
all those conversations we have it's
even the food stuff you know
remember it what i can tell you disney
knows a good troll
you know even the food stuff my my
episodes of
uh the wrong stuff you thought the broke
chinese food yes
he quick to disparage any type of
food positivity if he felt his food or
his region whatever
was better he had to come at you and let
you know don't worry that ain't it get
to you
yo but the funny thing like yo he he
knows like i'm i'm messing around
joking but he'll come in he was like no
you gotta come you gotta come to uh
you gotta come to texas get some real
food and yo you know what's crazy
like these they didn't know what i was
joking but yo when it comes to the whole
you gotta come over here
and get some real food like some real
good food yo he was thirsty
heal me about it as well it's like hell
barty i'm
where covert is like you need to come
over here i'm like yo dizzy
yo it's crazy like you know somebody
just meet on the internet for years upon
years having conversations
and how cool you can get with them yeah
dizzy was also
like a great supporter of me like he
would always come in my chats
uh he supported something that a lot of
people didn't even know that i do
this community like with the online
arcade yes like
this he was always in the chat so the
online he's like yeah jay barry i don't
know what's going on but this tournament
is fire yo
you told him it's hot you know what i
mean like i'm going while i'm watching
and this he's dm me he's like yo i got
some ideas for the online arcade
i think uh he definitely tried to
improve it as far as like getting
notoriety out there with with your
with your discord like yeah like a
fighting game segment yup he spearheaded
though
yeah like like dizzy like i agree 100
when he wants to support you and he when
he really rocks at you
there's no stopping him from supporting
you man and yes he he definitely did try
to
make me play arc he got you too
he's very serious about that arc man
like i i throw my little slanted hair in
there
and he it wasn't like oh he's throwing
slaying the back of the game
but he's trying to teach me about the
game i'm like wait i'm not going to go
that deep with art man
you know but it was cool it was cool to
hear him talking about
that stuff you know that he's passionate
about a specific game
you know um but like everybody said here
man like
over the years of of you know a little
back banter back and forth in the chats
that it developed to something where
you know we're chatting on discord we're
chatting on you know twitter dms
you know like like i said i can really
look at him like as that person that
he's a he's a franco it was just more
about
it was more than just gaming you know uh
i prefer
places he prefer it was more than that
with him man because
you can just you can you can definitely
feel that this guy is genuine when it
when it comes to the show you love or to
support you or just
trying to talk to you you know what i
mean like he he definitely will take the
time to
to to hear you out you know with certain
things even though it it
it could come from a troll post about
food
but he's like no i know you're trolling
but i really want you to come over here
and you know eat some good food you know
what i mean like
that's a great guy man and uh
it's just great to see that whether
whether you know where you we standing
game and all this i see a whole bunch of
people came in here
to show their respects to dizzy and
whether
whether it's small or large it it shows
how this this this one guy can
impact the whole community you know uh
with his presence
whether it's him bothering you one day
or
you know he'll communicate with you or
he see him in the chat you know
that one thing i i could definitely tell
too he he respected a lot of you guys uh
like all you guys an iron lords dude he
respected a lot of you
guys man like never no slander with you
guys
always positively positivity when it
comes to you guys and that you can
definitely tell when it comes to you
as far as you know iron lord and what
you guys you know have created with your
community you know
stuff there's definitely a tight bond
with you guys and you definitely could
tell especially with disney he
didn't look like he tried to recruit
everybody yeah
yeah facts yo you see oh you in the i
love podcast oh you cool let me see
what's going on
come on break come on here man come over
here he'll definitely try to bring you
in man but yo
big shout out to disney man my
condolences once again go out to the
family
like i he's he's one of those guys
that's really going to be missed
and it's heartbroken that you know you
know his time
has came but he would never be forgotten
with me man for sure like
you know i just the comic book talk man
was was was amazing like
you know his his opinions the movies was
a little bit suspicious
yeah you know what i mean but it was
great to just talk to somebody like that
you know just on a random
randomness meeting you in in a in a
podcast chat
and something that's developed to you
know a constant you know he would hit me
up he's like yo bar
you read this you know yo dizzy you read
this no so it was it was just cool just
to have that
that interaction with him man like i
said he will be missed but you'll never
be forgotten
well said brother and um i had to have
send the invite to you you know because
um you know
one thing people forget on twitter and
you know a lot of this console war and
stuff it get a little too deep for
certain people
but dizzy prove you know that he brought
people together
you know what i mean and you guys if i
technically in gaming talk you guys are
like the odd couple right you guys are
not supposed to be like
you know as far as allegiances and what
you like favorite wise console and
gaming and comics and all that stuff
but um it just goes and i used to watch
you guys banter and i would smile and
laugh
you know because because you guys would
go funny playfully you know what i'm
saying
go at it and stuff like that but i i saw
it was a true bond it was a true bond
that you guys have and um i'm glad you
said those stories too because uh again
it shows the type of person he is
you know it goes to show you what's
really important you know what i'm
saying in life
and yeah man that was my dude like when
i saw that news
yo cog no live man like i shut down like
i turned off twitter i turned off
everything i was
like yo no wait like it it
like i knew that he had cancer he didn't
outright just told me that he had it i
think i found out through
i forgot i forgot whose stream it was uh
where they did like uh
it was like a get-together kind of
stream and i saw it on like twitter you
know
helping out disney and all that stuff
probably yeah yeah so you know you know
you know
so i saw that through that but he never
really like brought that stuff up to me
with all the conversations that we had
like he never once brought up
cancer or anything like that and
anything that he feel in a certain type
of way like it was just always like
this is this is my me and jay barry
moment we're going to talk about comics
and
and and you know movies and you know
video games and stuff like that you know
we're just going to
chat it out you know and uh just
to find out that you know he did have
cancer and the whole cove and stuff and
all that
yeah like i agree with everybody man
this dude is a he was a strong guy
you know um that's not an easy thing
to just you know negate or to support in
the back burner
but he was doing that i guess for
everybody else's well-being
rather than himself so yeah you know
it's just
this great characteristics uh that this
guy had man
like i said he'd be missed man that was
my that's my dude man for real life for
sure for sure
it hurts that was my dude man yeah man i
want to
thank everybody that came out today
because um this was special
it was special to see everybody pull up
you know
celebrate the life of our brother he
touched us in so
many ways and and to see the gaming
community come through i see the chat i
see everybody online
everybody's personal story that it just
hit different and
we're all hurting but at the same time
it's good to see
how much he touched people and we we're
going to keep his memory alive he's
never
this this is not the end we're going to
promote his mission we're going to
support his wife his beautiful child you
know and um
i want to thank you guys again everybody
here
you know that took the time even if for
a minute
if you just you know said a few words
even if you wasn't on the zoom itself
and you're in the chat and you said a
few words
you know it meant a lot to see it and
this is this is the time i'm very proud
of the game i didn't know how i was
going to go you know and this was
something that i was
not looking forward to but one thing i
will say is that um
you know i was very conflicted on iop
this week and um i didn't think it was
appropriate
personally and i spoke to rose
and she said he would be furious
if you canceled iop
and when i thought about it i said you
know what she's right because at the end
of the day
iop and all the podcasts that he's been
a part of
that everyone either as a host here or
whatever
this was his therapy to get through what
he was getting through
right and he always told me he's like
[ __ ] you guys provide something for the
community
don't stop don't stop continuing on
so i said you know what let's give him
his his own day
which is today which is separate and um
things could continue the same thing
shout out to ibontis with last word he
would pop up in there
to slander destiny of course and um you
know but he
he was just man he was something special
he was funny
we we love him you know what i'm saying
again salutes his family his friends
everyone that pulled up
i mean we're going to immortalize them
in many ways you're never going to not
hear that name
but again i want to thank everybody that
came out tremendous tremendous again
last thing i'll say
um the link again the super chats are
great we appreciate it there's a link at
the top
however we would prefer which was the
gofundme link so that goes directly to
the family the services are officially
tomorrow when you saw
um these guys on but um
again this this was this was a special
turnout man and thank you again thank
everyone
again the entire gaming community this
is this is something special so what i'm
gonna do
to get us out of here again gaming
behind the box salute them
they put together a nice video that we
played earlier you know
tributing our brother saluting them so
we'll play that
and uh again salute i love you dizzy
never forgotten brother never forgotten
iron lord for life you already know
love welcome back to the next episode of
after hours it is may the 3rd of 2017
and we have things to talk about as well
as drinks to drink down
it's not just regular coffee i swear
there's there's
[Music]
hairs
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
last day of remediation treatment
just finished it up right now
and then on out i wanted to
give kind of a shout out to a few people
out there starting with uh of course
every sunday iron lords
especially to my boy cognito and king
david
all the support you guys thrown behind
that of course loads off and attic
of course everybody over there lognet
editor
josh redding editing staff
nick ryder's hector
uh site manager hyde wanted to give
another shout out to
of course will me
from will me over to mr bloomstick thank
you for everything you guys have done
bringing on uh rand and of course quick
to uh to do all that stuff take this
down
plan for the podcast shout out to you
guys at the shop
podcast
[Music]
special shout out to the wife
uh of course broken games over there a
weapon whale bringing me on
and there's a lot of other people do a
shout out and everything you know
especially out there on the twitterverse
porsche over season gaming
for all the support thrown back there i
just
wanted to thank you all for all the
support you've done and on to the next
step
one down thank you